MEETING. TO ORDER WILL GO AHEAD
AND BEGAN.
BY ESTABLISHING A QUORUM.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GOING HERE.
BIGELOW.
AND WE ARE VERY.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
DALY.
GALLAGHER. EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON HERE.
GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE.
LOW.
RUBIO.
SOLIS.
WALDRON
OKAY.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM WILL
LOOK FOR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SIR TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GRAY. AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW AYE
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN. BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
LACKEY I LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW. RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SO AS I WALDRON.
WALDRON I'VE SPENT.
OKAY THE CONSENT COUNTERS WITH
ADOPTED MEMBERS THAT INCLUDES
ITEM THREE ITEM FOR ITEM FIVE
AND ITEM SIX.
WE HAVE.
THE REMAINING ITEMS.
TO PRESENT TODAY THERE WILL BE
THREE PRESENTERS.
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH MISTER
STONE WHO IS IN. THE AUDIENCE
VICIOUS DON'T PLEASE COME ON UP
THIS.
MEMBERS IS.
ITEM TO AB TWENTY THREE OH WAIT.
WELCOME MR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY THREE AWAY.
WHAT TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY
THREE OH EIGHT WOULD DO WOULD BE
TO STOP THE SALE OF CIGARETTES
IN CALIFORNIA WITH FILTERS?
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE THINKING WHAT
AN INTERESTING IDEA.
BUT HERE'S THE BACKGROUND TO
THIS.
CIGARETTE FILTERS ARE CIGARETTE
* ARE THE MOST UBIQUITOUS
ITEM THAT WE FIND A COSTA
CLEANUPS RIVER CLEANUPS PARK AND
EVERYWHERE.
JUST WALK THE GROUNDS THE
CAPITAL AND YOU SEE CIGARETTE
* ALL OVER.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT TENDS TO BE
VERY UBIQUITOUS WHEREVER WE GO
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
UNAVOIDABLE IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
LITTER PROBLEM.
AND AS WE'RE TRYING TO REDUCE
THE IMPACT OF PLASTICS IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT
AND CIGARETTE FILTERS ARE
PLASTIC.
IT'S CELLULOSE ACETATE SO IT'S
PERVASIVE IN OUR ENVIRONMENT
DOES NOT BREAK DOWN.
IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE PLASTIC
THOUGHT WOULD BE AN INTERESTING
IDEA TO SEE HOW WE COULD REDUCE
THE IMPACT OF WHAT GETS TOSSED
INTO OUR ENVIRONMENT.
NOW MISTER CHAIR I WANNA THANK
YOU FOR THAT.
ANALYSIS HE WAS VERY THOROUGH IS
VERY LONG.
BUT IS ALSO VERY FAIR
CHARACTERIZATION OF. THE ISSUES
THAT WE REALLY FACE HERE BECAUSE
AS WE'VE TRIED TO TALK ABOUT
THIS BILL BEFORE.
WE GET LOST IN THE NOTION THAT
TAKING THE FILTER OFF A
CIGARETTE WOULD CREATE A MORE
DANGEROUS PRODUCT IN THE SCIENCE
SHOWS THAT THAT'S NOT TRUE.
WE GET KIND OF CAUGHT UP IN THE.
SO THAT THE MYTH THAT THE
CIGARETTE COMPANIES HAVE PUT ON
US OVER THE YEARS THAT ADDING
FILTERS WHICH WERE ADDED
STARTING IN THE FIFTIES AS THE
ANNOUNCES POINTS OUT.
ONCE CIGARETTES RULINGS TO LUNG
CANCER AND OTHER NEGATIVE HEALTH
EFFECTS.
AND.
SINCE THAT'S NO LONGER TRUE AND
SEND SMOKERS THAN SINCE I'VE
BEEN RUNNING THIS BILL I TALKED
TO A LOT OF SMOKERS BOTTOM DON'T
LIKE THIS AND I IDEA SOME OF
THEM DO LIKE THIS IDEA BUT ONE
OF THE COMMON THREADS.
AND THE CONVERSATION REALLY
STARTED WITH COULD WE GO TO A
REUSABLE FILTER COULD BE GO TO
SOME OTHER. ASPECT THAT WOULD
MAKE THE SMOKERS MORE
COMFORTABLE AND AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND AGAIN THEY SAY WE SMOKE.
WE TOSS
THE SMOKE.
WE TOSS.
SO WHY NOT TAKE THE STEP TO MAKE
WHAT GETS TOSSED.
A LESS ENVIRONMENTALLY HARMFUL
PRODUCT.
WE'RE NOT AFFECTING THE HEALTH
THE SMOKER.
AND THE AND THINK THAT THE
ANNOUNCES VERY CLEAR ON THAT AND
FRANKLY WHY THIS IS DOUBLE
REFERRED TO GEO AND THEN TO
HEALTH IS SOMETHING I DON'T
QUITE UNDERSTAND. DATA RESOURCES
MAYBE AND AS THE ANNOUNCES
POINTS OUT TO POTENTIALLY RATHER
TAX BECAUSE THERE'S CLEARLY SOME
ISSUES THAT THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED IN THEIR.
BUT THE HEALTH ISSUES ARE NOT
REALLY A PART OF WHAT THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH. NOR ARE
THEY SOMETHING THAT.
GETS PREVENTED BY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO TO ACCOMPLISH HERE AND
WE DO HAVE SOME TESTIMONY ABOUT
THAT.
SO LET'S CUT TO DRILL DOWN AT
THE IMPACT.
SEE IF THEIR CISCO TELLS US THAT
THEY SPEND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A
YEAR JUST CLEANING UP CIGARETTE
*.
CALTRANS TELLS US FORTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR JUST
CLEANING UP CIGARETTE*.
CITIES AND COUNTIES WHEN THEY'RE
DEALING WITH STORM WATER RUNOFF
NOW.
ARE FACED WITH A SITUATION THAT
THEY HAVE TO GET PERMITTED AND
SPEND MONEY ON CLEANING UP THAT
STORM WATER.
IF THERE WERE NO CIGARETTE.
BUT CIGARETTE FILTERS.
IN THAT RUNOFF
THEN THERE TASK WOULD BE EASIER
BECAUSE THE FILTERING THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO DO WOULD BE LESS
SIGNIFICANT.
AND THEY'RE THE ONES CARRYING
THE BRUNT OF PICKING UP THE
CIGARETTE*.
NOW I KNOW THE QUESTION ABOUT
LATER IS ALSO PREVALENT ONE AND
WHY DON'T WE JUST GO AFTER.
LETTER AND REYES THAT THE
PENALTIES FOR THAT. WELL
PENALTIES FOR LITTERING THROWING
A CIGARETTE OUT OF A CAR WE'VE
ALL SEEN IT SPECS IN THE
TWILIGHT THAT ORANGE RQ SOMEBODY
SMOKES TOSSED THE CIGARETTE OUT.
OR ON THE GROUNDS THE CAPITAL OR
ON A BEACH. THEIR FINES UP TO A
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
DO WE RAISE THAT TO TEN.
TO RESET THE FIVE I'M NOT SURE
THAT'S THE RIGHT WAY TO GO.
AND AGAIN SMOKERS TELL ME AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN THEY SMOKE.
AND THEY TOSS
SO I DON'T KNOW THAT WE CAN
CHANGE THAT BEHAVIOR I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE CAN UP THE PENALTY
SO MUCH.
THAT IT PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS THAT BECOMES A REAL
CHALLENGE.
SO.
FOR THIS BILL.
CHANGING THE PRODUCT
SLIGHTLY
AND IT'S NOT A SILLY AFFECTING
THE PRODUCT ITSELF BECAUSE MOST
CIGARETTE COMPANIES DO HAVE
FILLED WITH THE CIGARETTES THAT
THEY OFFER.
DOES EXIST BACK THAT'S BREWING
ALL THAT WAS THERE PRIOR TO THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES.
WHEN I GO BACK TO THOSE DAYS.
AND HAVE A PRODUCT AND THAT IS
THE DOES NOT CARRY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COST.
SO SOME OF THE YOU KNOW HAS
RAISES SOME ISSUES AS WELL MIKE
THOUGH FEDERAL PREEMPTION.
BECAUSE THE FDA HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR. THAT THEY REGULATE
CIGARETTES
BUT WHAT THEY REGULATORS THE
CONSTRUCTION.
OF CIGARETTES
NOT NECESSARILY THE CIGARETTE
ITSELF IS VERY CLEAR IN LAW.
AND THE CITY OF NEW YORK FOR
EXAMPLE HAS BANNED FLAVORED
CIGARETTES.
TO ME THAT GOES A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER TO THIS NOTION OF
CONSTRUCTION SINCE IT'S DECEIVE
NEW YORK TELLING THE CIGARETTE
COMPANIES WHAT CAN BE IN THEIR
PRODUCTS.
AND THAT PASSED THE TEST IN FACT
THIS THE FIRST AND SECOND.
CIRCUIT COURTS THOUGH ON THE
EAST COAST WHICH TEND O BE THE
ONE TO HEAR CIGARETTE CASES
AGREED. AND HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR
THAT.
STATES AND COUNTIES CAN IN FACT
BAN CIGARETTES WERE BANNED
CERTAIN TYPES OF CIGARETTES
SO I THINK THIS BILL WOULD VERY
CLEARLY. NOT BE PREEMPTED
BECAUSE WE'RE JUST SAYING FILTER
THE CIGARETTES WOULD BE OKAY IN
CALIFORNIA FILTERED CIGARETTES
WOULD NOT BE.
SO THAT I A TRIPS IS PROBABLY
NOT A PROBLEM ONE OF THE
SUGGESTIONS AS WHY DON'T WE
REQUIRE BIODEGRADABLE FILTERS.
WELL INTERESTING THOUGHT
ALTHOUGH OF THE TWO IDEAS
BANNING FILTERED CIGARETTES WAR
REQUIRE BIODEGRADABLE FILTERS
THE BIODEGRADABLE FILTERS NOW
GOES MORE TO THE CONSTRUCTION.
OF THE CIGARETTE.
THAT IS MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
THAT.
PREEMPTION ARGUMENT BUT JUST BE
ENDING A FILTERED CIGARETTE.
REALLY DOES NOT.
ALSO BE ANNOUNCES POINTS OUT THE
TAXATION ISSUES AND THE YEAR THE
REVENUE ISSUES AND THE PIRACY
ISSUES IN THE PIRACY ISSUE I
THINK IS SOMETHING THAT'S THAT'S
VERY SIGNIFICANT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THAT.
WE TALKED TO FIT THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD SEVERAL YEARS AGO WE
FIRST BROUGHT UP THIS IDEA. THEY
DID SAY THAT AS THE STATE PASSES
LAWS LIKE THIS WE WILL SEE A
SPIKE IN IN PIRACY.
BUT IT TAILS OFF AS PEOPLE GET
USED TO IT.
THE THIRTY PERCENT NUMBER OF.
PIRATED CIGARETTES IN CALIFORNIA
IS PROBABLY DRIVEN MORE BY THE
TWO DOLLARS.
A PACK TAX THAT WE PUT IN PLACE
THIS BODY PUT IN PLACE A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO IT WENT FROM EIGHTY
SEVEN CENTS A PACK.
A TWO DOLLARS AND EIGHTY SEVEN
CENTS A PACK
THAT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT DRIVER OF PIRACY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IF THIS BILL WERE TO PASS.
WOULD THAT IMPACT PIRACY IN
CALIFORNIA PERHAPS
BUT I THINK IT'S A LITTLE BIT
SPECULATIVE TO SAY HOW MUCH
SENATE'S IT'S CERTAINLY WORTH
STUDYING IT'S WORTH TAKING A
LOOK AT. WHAT WHETHER NOT THIS
WOULD REALLY DRIVE PIRACY OR
WAYS AROUND IT?
NOW I'VE BEEN HEARING ALSO FROM
I LOCAL RETAILERS AND I KNOW
WE'LL BE HEARING FROM SOME OF
THEM TODAY BECAUSE A LOT OF WHAT
WE DO IN SACRAMENTO DOES AFFECT
THE RETAILERS.
BUT TO THE RETAILERS AND HOW
EXPLAINED IT.
FOR THEM THE ONCE OF CONTACTED
ME IN MY IN MY DISTRICT.
THEY WOULD BE GETTING A SUPPLY
IF THIS WERE TO BE PUT IN PLACE.
OF NON FILTERED CIGARETTES THAT
THEY COULD THEN SO INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES SO THEIR SUPPLY
THEIR ABILITY TO KEEP THEIR
BUSINESS AND SELL CIGARETTES
SHOULD BE UNINTERRUPTED.
AND IF WE WANTED TO BUILD IN
SOME BUFFER SO THAT THEY CAN
SELL DOWN THEIR STOCK THAT WE
COULD FACE THIS AND. THAT'S THAT
WOULD BE FINE WITH ME BECAUSE I
DON'T NECESSARILY.
PART OF ME WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE
TO NOT BE SELLING CIGARETTES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IF WE HAVE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE BUILT AROUND
THAT THEN THIS BILL IS NOT
INTENDED TO INTERRUPT THAT. THIS
BILL IS REALLY INTENDED TO TAKE.
THAT
FILTER OUT OF OUR CIRCULATION
THAT'S REALLY THE GOAL SO FROM
WATER QUALITY STANDPOINT.
FROM A LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
STANDPOINT.
CLEAN UP THAT WE ALL HAVE TO DO.
TRY TO FIND WAYS TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF SMALL BUSINESS AND
PIRACY AND IN FACT I THINK THE
SMALL BUSINESSES. WOULD.
WHICH SHOULD BE BETTER SERVED IF
WE WOULD FIND SOME WAYS TO
ADDRESS THAT PIRACY.
THEY'RE THE ONES BEING HURT MOST
DIRECTLY BY THAT THIRTY PERCENT
CIGARETTES COMING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FROM OUTSIDE. THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE LOSING
THEIR SALES.
SO WE SHOULD BE ADDRESSING
PIRACY WE SHOULD BE TAKING A
MUCH HARDER LOOK AT THAT.
AND ON THE REVENUE SIDE AND THEY
KNOW THAT WOULD THAT WAS ALSO
BROUGHT UP BY THE ANNOUNCES. BUT
THE WHOLE REVENUE FROM
CIGARETTES IN CALIFORNIA IS HAS
BEEN ON A DECLINING BASIS ANYWAY
WE ARE SEEING UNFORTUNATELY
OPTICS IN VAPING UPTAKES IN
OTHER. DELIVERY SYSTEMSBUT
CIGARETTES ARE KIND OF GOING OUT
OF FASHION.
ADULTS FRANKLY A LOT OF FOLKS IN
MY GENERATION. WHO ARE STILL
SMOKING SMOKING IS LESS THAN
TWELVE PERCENT OF THE POPULATION
CALIFORNIA?
WHICH.
SHOULD RAISE THE QUESTION IF
IT'S LESS THAN TWELVE PERCENT
POPULATION WHY SO MUCH CIGARETTE
WASTE.
WELL AGAIN IT'S A DEDICATED
GROUP IT'S A GROUP THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO STOP
SMOKING IT'S A GROUP THAT
PROBABLY WOULD. SWITCH TO FILTER
THE CIGARETTES IF NECESSARY.
THEY'RE STILL SMOKING.
THEY SHOULD BE A PART OF.
THE SOLUTION THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING AND I I WILL HAVE TO
ADMIT THAT IN TALKING SOME THE
SMOKERS. WHO ARE A LITTLE BIT
LEERY OF TAKING THE FILTERS OFF
BECAUSE WE CHANGE THE TASTE?
IT WOULD CHANGE THE MOUTH FEEL.
CHANGE THAT SMOKE A LITTLE BIT
OF BUT IT BILL BUT OF THE
EXPERIENCE BUT THAT'S THE
TRADEOFF VERSUS THE SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL HARM.
NO TRADE OFTEN HARM TO THE
SMOKER THEMSELVES.
A LITTLE BIT OF INCONVENIENCE
WITH THE TASTE THE MOUTH FEEL
AND ALL THAT OF THIS MONTH.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
THE SCIENCE IS ACTUALLY THERE
SITES ESTABLISHES THIS IS A GOOD
IDEA.
SO FOR US THE QUESTION IS. IS
ARE THE OTHER ATTRIBUTES.
ENOUGH FOR US TO SAY WE
SHOULDN'T BE FACING THIS POLICY.
I THINK THE ANALYSIS SHOWS A
PATH.
FOR HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
GETTING OVER THE FEW YEARS
AROUND THE HEALTH OF THE SMOKER
BECAUSE THE FILTER DOESN'T
REALLY DO ANYTHING AND THAT IN.
IN THAT RESPECT.
BUT REALLY LOOKING AT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HARM.
AND KNOWING THAT THE SMOKERS
GOING TO SMOKE.
AND TOSS
LET'S MUCH MAKE WHAT THEY TOSS
LESS IMPACTFUL ON THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND I ASKED WE ARRIVE AT.
AND HAVE WITH ME SOME SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT INCLUDING DR TOM
NOVOTNY WHO IS ONE OF THE
LEADING RESEARCHERS ON EXACTLY
THIS ISSUE AND HAS BEEN TALKING
AT THE STATE. FEDERAL AND WORLD
LEVEL TO TRY AND INTRODUCED THIS
CONCEPT OF GETTING THIS FILTERED
THIS.
UNPRODUCTIVE BUT DAMAGING PIECE
OF A CIGARETTE OUT OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUT OF OUT OF
OUR WAY AS WE MOVE AHEAD TOWARDS
REDUCING PLASTIC IN. OUR
ENVIRONMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN THERE'S
MY NAME IS MICHELLE GIVEN THEM
WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT.
ARE SIXTY ONE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE CITY
ARE PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE AWAY.
AND A U. S. AS SURGEON GENERAL
OR PORTENT TWENTY FOURTEEN
HIGHLIGHTED THAT TOBACCO
MANUFACTURERS HAVE HISTORICALLY
UTILIZED MARKETING AND
ADVERTISING TERMS FOR SINGLE USE
FILTERS AND PRODUCTS SUCH AS
LIGHT LOW ARE MILD. WHICH LED TO
CONSUMERS FALSELY BELIEVING THAT
THE CIGARETTE PRODUCTS WERE LESS
HARMFUL TO THEIR HEALTH THAN
SMOKING REGULAR CIGARETTES.
ON THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND
THE SURGEON GENERAL AND THE CDC
HAVE CONCLUSIVELY DETERMINED
THAT THERE'S NO RISK FREE LEVEL
OF EXPOSURE TO TOBACCO AND NO
SAFE TOBACCO TO ADD TOBACCO
PRODUCT. EVEN THOSE UTILIZING AS
SINGLE USE FILTER AND FAX
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE IDENTIFIED
BY THE SURGEON GENERAL STRONGLY
SUGGEST THAT THE MODIFICATIONS
TO THE CIGARETTE DESIGN
INCLUDED.
INCLUDING THE ADDITION OF THE
ALTERATIONS TO THE SINGLE USE
FILTERS HAVE NOT DECREASED AND
SMOKING NICOTINE INTAKE OR THE
RISKS OF CERTAIN TYPE OF CANCERS
AND IN FACT MAY HAVE INCREASE
THEM.
AND WE EXPECT THAT THE PASSAGE
OF THIS MEASURE WOULD LEAD TO A
DECREASE RISK IN THE NECK AND
NICOTINE POISONING RESULTING
FROM ILLEGAL LETTER. OF
CIGARETTES AND CIGARETTE FILTERS
WHICH CAN BE EXTREMELY TALK
TOXIC PARTICULARLY TO CHILDREN
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF POISON CONTROL
CENTERS BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX AND TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
APPROXIMATELY TWELVE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED INJURIES OCCURRED
DUE TO THE INGESTION OF
CIGARETTES. AND SINGLE USE
FILTER TIPS AT THE MAJORITY
WHICH WERE AMONG CHILDREN UNDER
THE AGE OF SIX
SO AND IT'S FOR THESE REASONS
THAT WE WOULD STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MOTION.
MY NAME IS THOMAS ABOUT ME I'M A
PHYSICIAN AND PROFESSOR OF
PUBLIC HEALTH SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO HAVE A COUPLE
MINUTES HERE CHAIRMAN BRAND
MEMBERS.
I JUST WANT TO.
FURTHER DISPEL THE NOTION THAT
THE THE CIGARETTE FILTER HAS ANY
HEALTH BENEFIT IN FACT ISSUES
POINTED OUT JUST NOW.
THEIR USE OF THE FILTER MEANS
EUROPE YOU'RE INHALING AGAINST
AND OBSTRUCTION MEANS YOU INHALE
THE SMOKE MORE DEEPLY INTO YOUR
LUNGS. AND THAT MEANS THAT IT'S
CHANGE THE CELL TYPE OF THE LUNG
CANCER THAT IT IS CAUSED BY
CIGARETTE SMOKING FROM SMALL
CELL TO MY MORE AGGRESSIVE TYPE
OF CANCER CALLED ADENOCARCINOMA.
THE RISKS FOR SMOKING THE RISK
FOR LUNG CANCER RATHER HAVE GONE
UP ACTUALLY OVER THE LAST FIFTY
OR SIXTY YEARS SINCE THE ENGINE
AT THE INTRODUCTION OF THIS
FRAUDULENT.
ATTEMPT TO MAKE A CIGARETTE
SAFER IT JUST DOESN'T WORK.
NOW THE.
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES IS PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT AS A AS A.
MISS STONE'S POINTED OUT THERE
SEVENTEEN BILLION CIGARETTES
SOLD YEARLY IN CALIFORNIA STILL
EVERY YEAR SEVENTY BILLION GET
DUMPED SOMEWHERE THAT'S WHY IT
IS THE MOST COMMON THING PICKED
UP ON BEACHES IN URBAN CLEAN UPS
THROUGHOUT THIS STATE BUT ALSO
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD OVER THE
LAST THIRTY OR FORTY YEARS.
WE'VE DONE DONE THE SITE
CLEANUPS NON BIODEGRADABLE
PLASTIC.
I IN THE REST OF THE CIGARETTE
IS BIODEGRADABLE SO THAT WITHOUT
IT ONE WOULD THINK IT YOU WOULD
HAVE MUCH LESS OF A.
INSULT TO THE ENVIRONMENT BY
HAVING AN UNFILTERED CIGARETTE.
THAT'S TOSSED BY SMOKERS AS
THEY HAVE.
THIS ISSUE OF THE STORM WATER
REGULATION I THINK THAT WE MAY
JUST REMIND YOU THAT THERE'S A
CALIFORNIA CLEAN WATER ACT. THAT
HAS THE TRASH AND ADMIT THAT
WILL REQUIRE COMMUNITIES
TO WITHIN THE NEXT TEN YEARS OF
PROHIBIT ANYTHING GREATER THAN
FIVE MILLIMETERS FROM GOING TO
STORM WATER SYSTEMS. AND THAT
WOULD INCLUDE CIGARETTE* SO
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE SOME
EXPENSE EITHER IN THE FILTRATION
PROCESS THE CLEAN OUT.
AND SOMETHING IT'S A LOT MORE
COST EFFECTIVE WOULD BE TO BAN
THE UPSTREAM A PRODUCT THAT'S
GOING GOING TO BE.
COLLECTING IN THE IN THE IN THE
STORM WATER.
.
THERE IS THE OTHER. PIECE THAT I
ALSO WANT TO DISPEL AND THIS WAS
MENTIONED IN THE EMAIL.
IN THAN IN THE.
VERY EXCELLENT REPORT BY THE
WHEN I I WAS REALLY IMPRESSED
WITH THAT AS WELL. AND
THOROUGHNESS IT WAS DONE UP BUT
THERE WAS A MENTION MADE THAT.
.
ON THE.
FTA WAS GOING TO PREEMPT.
THIS.
ISSUE OF OF OF CHANGING THE
PRODUCT WHILE THE STATE WOULD
NOT BE CHANGED IN THE PRODUCT
ONLY THE FDA CAN REGULATE THE
CONTENT OF THAT MANUFACTURE THE
PRODUCT UNDER THE FAMILY PREVENT
A SMOKING PREVENTION TOBACCO
CONTROL ACT OF THE VOICE ON THE
C.. T. CA WITH STATES CAN DO
THOUGH IS IS SPELLED OUT IN THE
SAVINGS CLAUSE OF THE
LEGISLATION FROM TWO THOUSAND
NINE.
CRITICS ABILITY OF STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
TO YOU RELATIVE TO.
OR PROHIBITING THE SALE
DISTRIBUTION POSSESSION EXPOSURE
TO ACCESS TO ADVERTISING OF
PROMOTION OF OR USE OF TOBACCO
PRODUCTS IN OTHER WORDS THE
STATE HAS THE ABILITY. AND WE'VE
PUBLISHED THIS IN THE HAMLINE
LAW REVIEW MY COLLEAGUES SAID OF
WE MITCHELL SCHOOL OF LAW SAY
JUST THIS THAT THE STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN DO THIS.
SHOULD THE STATE NOT DECIDE TO
GO THROUGH WITH THIS OF BILLS
THAT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAIN
FACT TAKEN UP. I'M WORKING NOW
WITH MY COLLEAGUES WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO DEVELOP A CENTER ON
TOBACCO IN THE ENVIRONMENT AT
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
FUNDED BY THE TOBACCO RELATED
DISEASE RESEARCH PROGRAM.
TO.
HELP OTHER COMMUNITIES
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY CAN DO TO
PRESENT OUR PREVENT.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL.
IMPACTS OF.
SECRET BUT IT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME I HOPE YOU DO. CONSIDER
THIS AGAIN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS TOSSED MILAN
I'M I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF FOUR
DIFFERENT GROUPS A AND I WANT TO
STRESS THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
WHICH YOU HEARD AND EXCELLENT.
AT TEST ME ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACTS WE HEAR FOR HEAL THE BAY
WHICH IS AN ADVOCACY GROUP IN
SUDDEN CALIFORNIA'S BEEN WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE FOR MANY YEARS.
AND HAS LED AMONGST OTHER GROUPS
THAT THE CHARGE ON CLEANING UP
THE BEACHES ARE THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY WHICH WILL SAY IS
CHARGED TO. A HELP KEEP ITS
COMMUNITY CLEAN.
WHICH STAR CHUMASH FUND IN THE
SEVENTH GENERATION ADVISES BUT
JUST A SPECIFICALLY ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ASPECTS.
THIS IS NOT AN OUTRIGHT BAN WE
TRIED BAND BEFORE BECAUSE THIS
IS NOT AN OUTRIGHT BAN THIS IS A
PREFERRED I'M SURE FOR MANY
PEOPLE A PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE
TO AN OUTRIGHT BAN. A DIS THESE
SO FILTERS ARE NOT BIODEGRADABLE
AND THAT IS WHAT IS THE SINGLE
BIGGEST PROBLEM FROM AN
ENVIRONMENTAL PERSPECTIVE YOU'VE
HEARD THAT IT IT CHOKES UP THE.
THE.
STORMWATER DRAINS A AND THEN
FINALLY IN TWENTY OR THIRTY
YEARS OF COASTAL CLEANUP AND
OTHER CLEAN UPS WE HAVE NOT SEEN
A CHANGE IN PATENT.
IN SOME AREAS WE HAVE SEEN A
CHANGE IMPACT WE HAVE SEEN
PEOPLE A DAY LITTERING WE HAVE
NOT IN THIS CASE UNFORTUNATELY
MAYBE IT'S THE PRACTICE MAYBE
IT'S THE SIZE OF THE FILTER.
WHAT'S LEFT OF THE BUT IT'S EASY
TO THROW THAT AWAY AND QUITE
FRANKLY WE HAVESEEN VERY VERY
LITTLE REDUCTION NO MATTER WHAT
EDUCATION OUTREACH TO HAS BEEN.
YOU SEEM VERY RIVER LITTLE
REDUCTION IN THE LETTERING OF
THIS SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE BILL AND
THANK THE AUTHOR.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TERRY MEMBERS MELISSA
ROMERO THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT.
THERESA BURKE REG ON BEHALF OF
ZERO WASTE USA THE FIVE GYRES
INSTITUTE WILD COAST PACIFIC.
ARPS I PLASTIC POLLUTION
COALITION AN UPSTREAM POLICY AND
SUPPORT.
KELLY BUCKS ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERESA COOK ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR
SUPERVISORS ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AND JENNIFER COMPUTER LOW ON
BEHALF OF THE MONTEREY COUNTY
UBER SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SAVAGE WITH THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
SYLVIA'S A LEASH ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA WE
THINK THIS BILL WOULD GO A LONG
WAY IN HELPING TO KEEP CLEAN ONE
OF THE BUSIEST BEACHES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THINKING.
OKAY TO RECEIVE THE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION
.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN
LATTIMER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION.
IN OPPOSITION.
OUR OUR RETAIL MEMBERS
CERTAINLY RESPECT THAT THERE IS
AN ISSUE HERE I'M DEALING WITH
LETTER THAT. I'M IS A CONCERN IN
MANY COMMUNITIES NOT JUST
COASTAL COMMUNITIES.
WE WOULD HOWEVER.
OF JACK TO THE THOUGHT THAT THE
WAY TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF TO
USE THE DOCTOR'S NUMBERS. PARKS
MAY SEVENTEEN BILLION.
CIGARETTES SOLD A FAR AWAY
MAJORITY THEM ART WINDING UP ON
OUR BEACHES I DON'T WANT TO. I
KNOW THAT THE NUMBERS QUOTED
ANALYSIS THAT TALK ABOUT. SOME
CIGARETTE* PICKED UP IN IN A
RECENT SURVEY OF BEACH CLEAN UP
THE STILL A FRACTION OF WHAT
GETS LITTERED I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT WE STILL ARE TALKING ABOUT.
A FRACTION OF WHAT IS OTHERWISE
WE BELIEVE APPROPRIATELY
DISPOSED OF BY LEGAL CIGARETTE
SALES. A LEGAL PRODUCT A
CIGARETTE SALES ON OUR OUR.
CERTAINLY ASSOCIATE OURSELVES
WITH A LOT OF THE INFORMATION IS
PROVIDED FOR ANALYSIS THAT PUTS
LEGAL SMOKERS HAVE DEALT WITH
NUMEROUS CHANGES IN STATE LAW IN
THE IN RECENT PAST. ON MANY OF
THOSE WE UNDERSTAND WERE
IMPORTANT POLICY MATTERS RAISING
CIGARETTE SMOKING AGE TO
INCREASING RECENTLY CIGARETTE
TAXES I'M OVER THE SEVEN YEARS
AGO MOVING PEOPLE FROM SMOKING
INDOORS AT SUCH A NUMBER OF
THOSE POLICIES.
AGAIN LEGAL SMOKERS UNDERSTOOD
AND HAVE AND HAVE GRAPPLED WITH
AN ADDRESSED.
LEGAL SMOKERS TODAY HAVE A
CHOICE OF A FILTER CIGARETTE
UNFILTERED CIGARETTE THAT IS
TRUE AND YET THE CHOICE OF THE
OVERWHELMINGLY MAKE IS FOR
FILTERED CIGARETTE NORTH OF
NINETY PERCENT OF THE SALES OR.
FILTERED CIGARETTES AND SO THIS
IS YET ANOTHER IN THEIR EYES IN
THE EYES OF THE RETAILERS THAT
THAT WORK WITH THEIR CUSTOMERS
THIS IS ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE TO WHAT IS OTHERWISE A
LEGAL PRODUCT. WE'D CERTAINLY
SYMPATHIZE AND UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFICULT IN FRUSTRATION.
IN ALL COMMUNITIES NOT JUST
BEACH COMMUNITIES ABOUT LETTER
AND CERTAINLY WOULD SUPPORT MORE
TO BE DONE TO EDUCATE AND IN
FACT I DON'T THINK A TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE IS
WARRANTED BUT SOME ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT AROUND LETTER WILL
STICK MAKES SENSE.
AND THIS IS UNFORTUNATELY FOR
FOR THE RETAIL COMMUNITY FOR THE
CUSTOMERS THAT WE SERVE YET
ANOTHER.
IF YOU WILL D
IS THEIR ABILITY TO CONSUME A
LEGAL PRODUCT
BUT THAT MAY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOBLE.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GENEROUSLY
PREFER THE CALIFORNIA SUGARS
SOCIALIZATION.
HARD DATA SHOWS THAT NINETY
NINE POINT SEVEN PERCENT OF
THOSE CIGARETTES HOLDING BUYER
DISTRIBUTORS WHICH FOR THOSE
LARGEST IN THE COUNTRY. AND IN
CALIFORNIA.
ART FILTERED CIGARETTES
SO THREE TENTHS OF ONE PERCENT
OR NON FILTERED.
OF THE QUESTION BECOMES AS TO
WHERE DOES THAT CONSUMER GO TO.
.
TOOK TO STILL BE ABLE TO GET
FILTERED CIGARETTES BECAUSE
I'M NOT CONVINCED THAT YOU'RE
GONNA MOVE THAT BIGGER
POPULATION AWAY FROM WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN USED TO.
THE IT'S COULD HAVE TO BE
CONTRABAND IT'S EITHER GONNA
HAVE TO BE BOUGHT OFF OF. OUR
TRIBAL LAND NO TAX PAID HOUSE TO
BE BOUGHT BY MAIL ORDER NO TAX
PAID. ALL OF THE ALL OF THE
AREAS THAT.
WILL WHERE YOU CAN WILL BE ABLE
TO BUY THE PRODUCT WILL BE
CONTRABAND PRODUCT.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT
THAT'S THAT'S GOING TO STOP
PEOPLE FROM DOING THAT.
URINALYSIS IS VERY CORRECT THAT
RIGHT NOW WITH RAISINS SURTAX.
OUR COUNTRY BANDS COME BACK UP
AGAIN AND IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE
THIS WOULD JUST EXASPERATED. ARE
FOR THOSE REASONS SINCE MIGHT
MEMBERS ARE THE TAXPAYERS WE
MUST POSE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RICHARD
MARX AND ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PETROLEUM AND
CONVENIENCE STORE ASSOCIATION OF
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE HERE
TODAY TO EXPRESS THEIR CONCERN.
THAT WE AGREE ACTUALLY WITH ONE
OF THE PROPONENTS OF THE MEASURE
THAT SAID THAT OF BEHAVIOR
DOESN'T CHANGE VERY MUCH WE
HAVEN'T SEEN A WHOLE LOT OF
CHANGE IN BEHAVIOR. AND WE THINK
THAT THAT ACTUALLY ARGUES
AGAINST THE BILL BUT WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT OF BANNING THE
FILTERED CIGARETTE SALES AS MR
LOW PER POINTS OUT HEARD NINETY
NINE PERCENT OF CIGARETTE SALES.
IN CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO A
SOMEHOW CHANGE THE PREFERENCE OF
THOSE SMOKERS WHO ARE BUYING
FILTERED CIGARETTES AND.
IT CHANGED INTO A STARK
CONSUMING A NON DISPOSABLE
FILTER AND.
A FOR A FILTER A CIGARETTE OR
SMOKING A JUST A PLAIN CIGARETTE
A WE THINK THAT IS MISTER LOCAL
POINTS OUT OF THAT WE WILL SEE
AN UPTICK. NOT ENCONTRABAN
SALES.
THAT WILL AT LEAST EXCEED OF
WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH THE
CIGARETTE TAX INCREASE AND
UNFORTUNATELY.
SINCE MANY OF MY MEMBERS DEPEND
UPON CIGARETTE SALES FOR AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THEIR INCOME
OF THIS IS GOING TO HAVE A
DIRECT IMPACT ON THEM AND IT
WILL AS IT WAS POINTED OUT IN
THE ANALYSIS. HAVE A DIRECT
IMPACT ON THE STATE FROM THE
LOSS OF THE REVENUE FOR THAT
REASON THE ELEVEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF AFRICA ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO MY NAME IS KEVIN DETROIT
CAR I'M THE PRESIDENT ABOUT
PRESS SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
REPRESENT OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
BUSINESSES. AND WE OPPOSE AB
TWENTY THREE LA THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JEFF CASH DEAL I HAVE
BUSINESSES IN CERES CALIFORNIA
TRACY CALIFORNIA.
MOST SMALL BUSINESSMEN.
I CAN EMPATHIZE WITH THE ISSUE
BUT I GUESS THE SOLUTION
PROPOSED HERE. IS IS FATAL TO A
LOT OF SMALL BUSINESSES SO. I
WOULD REQUEST A NO WARRANTY
BETWEEN IF YOU LIKE FIX.
JOHN DIRTY WITH THE CIVIL
JUSTICE SOLUTION CALIFORNIAN
OPPOSITION CONCERNED OVER THE
CIVIL PENALTIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU NEVER.
ALLEN THERE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE FOR AND
XIN.
DROUGHT COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND WE OPPOSE.
SEND YOU BUT DON'T SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER FROM.
PARA TO EDEA.
AND WOOD. NO ON THIS BILL. ONLY
ONE SENTENCE TO EXPAND THIS BILL
IS. THE ROAD TO HELL WAS PAVED
WITH GOOD INTENTIONS.
MY QUESTION THE BOUNCING FROM UP
ON AUTO PRESIDENT OF BATF UP A
CHAPTER. AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR RUSSELL
NO ACT ON BEHALF OF SEE ALMA. WE
REPRESENT CONVENIENCE STORES UP
AND DOWN THE STATE.
OPPOSE THE BILL.
SENATE COMMITTEE UP FROM CITY OF
THE SUN SOUNDS COUNTY.
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER WE HELP
HOME PLUMAS STORES AYE OPPOSED
A. B. TWENTY THREE WAIT.
DISCERNABLE BUT I PROBLEM AGGRO
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND SO HE SAID TO THE PRESIDENT
THAT CUT CHAPTER CENTRAL VALLEY.
HAVE THE BUSINESSES AND MERCED
AND ALL HIGH AND ASK FOR OPPOSE
THAT MOVE VOTE ON NOBODY.
DO YOU THINK TO LIVE IN MODESTO.
I HAVE A BUSINESS IN CERES
INVESTOR HOA THINGS AS HYSTERIA
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IMAGES SAID LUPRON BADIA Y.
SPAYED AND UP.
AND I HAVE A BUSINESS IN
SUNNYVALE SANAGA I'M BAD I'M AYE
OPPOSED TO SPENT I THINK.
MY NAME IS A DANDY ASSIGNEE I'M
PROM ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA HAVE A
BUSINESS THERE I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS GOODS THAN THE SINGLE
ON THE LINE FROM AND GROW FROM A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER I POSE THIS
BEEN.
HELLO MY NAME'S MARAT SANDRA I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING OUR
CHAPTER IN LA PARAPPA. COVERS A
FOR COUNTIES SAN MARINO LOS
ANGELES RIVERSIDE AND ORANGE.
AND I'M HERE PERSONALLY. FOR MY
STORES AS WELL IN ANAHEIM AND
BOND BILL.
NO.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KAMEL PRINT BULLARD
AND I HAVE A BUSINESSES IN
MULTIPLE CITIES OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE ABUSE CHAU
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO I HAVE A
SMALL BUSINESS AND I REQUEST YOU
ALL KNOW WHAT ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HAVE THEY'VE
SAYING I WOULD BEGIN A CINNAMON
SUGAR NOAH OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME WE BECAUSE THERE'S A
ARAMBULA I HAVE SOME BUSINESS IN
GEORGE MADE THROUGHOUT PLAN AT
GROW.
STAND DAYS AND.
CRITICS WOULD INVENT SO I HOPE
WE'VE JUST BEEN.
MY NAME IS PUT THERE SAYING I'M
CAME FROM KNOW A RADICAL AND
SOON THOUGH.
I'M GONNA PART OF OUR.
FROM ALAMEDA.
SOLANO COUNTY.
LEARN QUOTED SMALL MIDDLEMAN. I
PULL THIS BIT THANK.
HAVE A NAMES PAUL HERE AND.
FROM NAPA AND I POSE THIS BILL
THINK.
MY NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE THINK
ARMY I'M GROWN UP BY AND SOLANO
COUNTY I HAVE A COUPLE BUSINESS
I'M OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I THINK.
OPENED THAT THINGS TO DO FROM
TRACY.
I OPPOSED TO TWENTY THREE OH
EIGHT.
ANNOUNCING FROM TRACY OPPOSE THE
TWO THREE ZERO EIGHT.
JUST VENDOR AND SMOG DISTANCING
TRACY I PRODUCE BEEN.
MY NAME IS A HARRY SANGHA OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
SACRAMENTO BEGINS SO.
HELLO MY NAME IS SUMA THING I'M
HOME SITS A SITE AND A RANCHO
CORDOVA I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OR OTHERWISE.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS.
THE QUESTION MEMBERS MISTER
GALLAGHER.
LEARN.
MR STILL NO ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU BROUGHT UP WAS A PIRACY
ISSUE AND YOU RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT IS THAT IS A. POTENTIAL
PROBLEM HERE YOU KNOW IT WITH
THE RECENT TAX WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN LOTS PEOPLE BRING IN AND
OUT OF STATE.
CIGARETTES THAT'S THAT'S
UNDERMINE WE ARE THE SEATED THE
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO TESTIFIED
HERE THIS MORNING.
SO I SAW YOU RECOGNIZE THAT AS
A PROBLEM BUT.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO TO?
YOU DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT I
GUESS BECAUSE IF THAT'S A REAL
SIDE EFFECT HOW CAN WE.
HOW CAN WE ENFORCE THAT HOW CAN
WE IN SURE THAT? THAT'S NOT
GOING TO CONTINUE TO UNDERMINE.
WELL AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT WE PUT THAT THE
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR.
PENALTY IN THERE WHICH WAS ALSO
SO. OPPOSED TO TO TRY AND AND
SET A BAR.
I THINK WE HAVE A BIGGER PROBLEM
TO FACE AND THAT'S PIRACY IN
SALES OF CIGARETTES WHETHER IT'S
FROM.
THE TRIBES OR OUT OF STATE FOR
ON LINE BECAUSE YOU ARE FROM A
LOT OF BUSINESSES. THEY DEPEND
ON THE SALE OF CIGARETTES REALLY
FOR THEIR BUSINESS.
WOULD THIS HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
INCREMENT DRIVE SOME PIRACY
POTENTIALLY THAT'S SOMETHING
ABSOLUTELY THAT THAT'S WERE
STARTING IN TAKING A LOOK AT.
BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT JUST
INCREASING FINES AND PENALTIES
AND.
IS IS REALLY GOING TO TO DO THE
JOB I THINK WE HAVE TO DO OF A
BIGGER PICTURE JOB IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND INFORM PEOPLE ABOUT ABOUT
WHAT'S AT STAKE SO THAT THEY'RE
MAKING.
MORE INFORMED CHOICES.
I WOULD THINK ANNA AND I
UNDERSTAND THE OPPOSITION HERE
CHANGING THE PRODUCT HAVING NO
FILTERS.
ON A CIGARETTE.
MIGHT DISSUADE SOME PEOPLE FROM
CONTINUING TO SLOW A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT I TALK TO I'M NOT
CONVINCED THAT THAT'S TRUE WILL
LISTEN TWELVE PERCENT IT'S A
DECLINING GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE SMOKING. THEY'RE PRETTY
DETERMINED TO CONTINUE TO SMOKE.
SO I I DON'T KNOW THEY PROBABLY
WOULD A LOT OF THEM WOULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE FILTER THE
CIGARETTE BECAUSE THEY'RE BOUND
AND DETERMINED TO.
CONTINUE THAT HABIT.
WOULD THEY GET IT OUT OF STATE
WOULD THEY GET IT FROM THE
TRIBES THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK
WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND
FIGURE OUT A MORE EFFECTIVE WAY
OF OF ENFORCEMENT.
S. THROWING NUMBERS AND AND
PENALTIES.
LEADS TO MAY NOT SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
LISA OTHER ISSUES IN SO FOR
WHETHER IT'S FOR THIS BILL OR
WHETHER IT'S FOR THE THE LARGER
PROBLEM OF CIGARETTE PIRACY.
WE.
I THINK THAT'S UP TO ALL OF US
TO TO. TO LOOK AT HOW WE PROTECT
THE BUSINESS THAT THAT IS LOCAL
IN CALIFORNIA AND IF WE ARE
GOING TO SELL A PRODUCT. THAT IT
STAYS.
SO KNOW THAT THIS BILL WOULD
HAVE.
BE THAT SIGNIFICANT OF A DRIVER
OBVIOUSLY TWO DOLLARS A PACK
THAT'S A MUCH BIGGER DRIVER
PEOPLE MAKE DECISIONS. BASED ON
THE THEIR WALLETS MORE THAN THEY
DO ON THE PRODUCT
AND THEY'VE BEEN SOLD. A BILL OF
GOODS FOR MANY YEARS ON THE
BENEFITS OF THE FILTER FILTER
DOESN'T REALLY PROVIDE THOSE
BENEFITS.
ONCE THEY UNDERSTAND THAT WORK
THAT PRODUCTS NOT AVAILABLE BILL
ITEM WILL SWITCH TO AN
UNFILTERED CIGARETTE AND
CONTINUE WOULD HAVE IT. THAT'S
NOT A GOOD THING IN IN MY BOOK
BUT I THINK THAT'S A SITUATION
WE HAVE.
THIS IS GONNA JUMP IN AND.
CORRECT WHAT I THINK YOU MEANT
TO SAY AND YOU CAN CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG BUT YOU CONFLATED.
LEGAL SALES. OF CIGARETTES ON
TRIBAL LAND AND PIRACY AYE IN
THE BEER YOUR COMMENTS THERE AND
I THINK.
THE BLACK MARKET ILLEGAL SALES
OBVIOUSLY.
DIFFERENT ISSUES IT ABSOLUTELY
UNIFIED GETS GOOD POINT THAT WAS
NOT MY INTENTION BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE ILLEGAL SALE.
OUR STATE OR A LEGAL SALE.
IN A TRIBAL SITUATION RIGHT.
THOSE CORRECT TO GOING OUT OF
STATE WOULD BE ILLEGAL SELLING A
CIGARETTE EVEN UNDER THIS BILL.
ADD ON TRIBAL LAND IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD NOT BE ILLEGAL SO SOMEBODY
DID GO AND AND ACQUIRE
CIGARETTES ON TRIBAL LANDS AND
THEN CAME BACK INTO CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S NOT IT WOULD BE DOES IT
CONTRIBUTES TO THE TAX ISSUE
BUT.
OKAY ABSENT OR CONTRIBUTES TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE TAX ISSUE
RIGHT NOW YOUR YOUR THAT'S A
GOOD POINT BECAUSE THERE'S
THERE'S DEFINITELY A LINE THERE
SO GOING OUT OF STATE WERE
TRYING TO SUPPLY. INTO
CALIFORNIA AND IN FACT UNDER
THIS BILL POTENTIALLY DRIVING
INTO ANOTHER STATE ACQUIRING
CIGARETTES AND BRINGING THEM IN
FOR PERSONAL USE.
IS NOT AN OFFENSE UNDER THIS IT
WOULD BE.
BRINGING IN CIGARETTES AND SO
THE HOPE WOULD BE THAT ALL OF
THE RETAILERS WHO RELY ON THE
SALE OF CIGARETTES FOR THEIR
BUSINESS THEIR SUPPLY CHAIN.
WOULD BE PROVIDING THEM THE
APPROPRIATE CIGARETTES TO SOW.
AND AS LONG AS THEY'RE GETTING
UNFILTERED CIGARETTES IN THE
SAME QUALITY THAT THEY WERE
OTHERWISE A FILTER CIGARETTES
AND THOSE ARE STILL SELL
SELLING.
THERE'S BEEN IN THAT INSTANCE
NOT IMPACT ON THE.
IT CERTAINLY DOES ILLUSTRATE.
THE DIFFICULTY.
THAT WE FACED WITH BLACK MARKET
ISSUES AROUND TOBACCO THAT'S NOT
THE ISSUE IN THE.
.
IT'S AN ISSUE THIS COMMITTEES
VERY FAMILIAR WITH AND HAS BEEN
FOR SEVERAL DECADES
AS-CALIFORNIA HAS STRUGGLED TO.
A
REDUCE BLACK MARKET SALES I
THINK THEY STILL REPRESENT
SOMEONE THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
THIRTY PERCENT. OF TOBACCO SALES
IN THE STATE.
WHICH CONTINUES TO BE A CONCERN
BUT WE CERTAINLY MADE EFFORTS.
THIS BILL DOES PRESENT.
THOSE CHALLENGES.
I CERTAINLY COMMEND YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO TRY DRESSES ISSUE
I THINK THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE.
THAT BODY AGREES THAT THE
LITTERING ISSUE AS IT RELATES TO
STRIP MUCH IS A IS A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE AND ONE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
I THINK WE CONTINUE TO DISAGREE.
ON THE APPROACH.
TO TAKE YOU KNOW CERTAINLY.
THE BLACK MARKET ISSUE.
IS FIRST AND FOREMOST ON MY
MIND.
.
BUT THE HOUSE IT HEALTH ISSUE
ALSO ARE TO MAP I WANTED STATE
DEPT YOU TO ASK THE GENTLEMAN
FROM SAN DIEGO YOU. RAISE THE
ISSUE OF FILTERED CIGARETTES.
PRESENTING AN ADDITIONAL HEALTH
CONCERN OVER UNFILTERED
CIGARETTES
AND I'M CURIOUS IF THAT WERE THE
CASE.
OR IF THAT IS THE CASE AND IF
THE SCIENCE.
IS CLEAR ON THAT
AND WHY THE FDA HASN'T TAKEN
ACTIONS TO BE HIM FILTERED
CIGARETTES.
WHAT MY THOUGHTS ARE ON THAT?
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
ACTOR I JUST TO STEP DOWN AS
DEPUTY ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
HEALTH IN HHS AND I GET IN THAT
POSITION I. CO CHAIRED WITH THE
SURGEON GENERAL THE INTERAGENCY
COMMITTEE ON THE BACK ON HEALTH
I WAS BRINGING THIS ISSUE
FORWARD UNTIL.
UNTIL ELECTION HAPPENED.
AND THEN I HAD TO.
CHANGE CHAU MY YOU KNOW MY
VENUE BUT.
THE.
AT THE QUESTIONS I DID ASK THE
FDA ON THIS.
WERE.
RECEIVED WITH INTEREST AND I
THINK THEY ARE INTERESTED IN IN
THIS ISSUE. AT WHAT THE CAME
BACK TO ME.
AND
TERMS OF THEIR.
A REASON NOT TO DO THIS IS THIS
COULD BE DONE AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND ACTUALLY SUGGESTED THAT THAT
MAYBE A BETTER ROUTE THAN TRYING
TO DEAL WITH. THE LAWSUITS THAT
THEY GET AGAINST THE FTA
INCESSANTLY FROM THE TOBACCO
INDUSTRY THAT JUST.
STOPS EVERYTHING THEY'RE TRYING
TO DO WHAT THEY CAN AND
INCREMENTAL BASIS TO REGULATE
TOBACCO IN THIS ONE IT WAS OF A
BIG STEP FOR THEM TO TAKE.
NOW I KNOW THERE'S BEEN ARE.
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS OF THESE
ARGUMENTS MADE
THAT TRANSITIONING. CONSUMERS TO
E. CIGARETTES ARE CAN HAVE SOME
PERIPHERAL OR OR BYPRODUCT
HEALTH BENEFIT.
STRIKES ME THAT WOULD ALSO
POTENTIALLY HAVE. A BENEFIT IN
THIS AREA IS THAT. GONNA FOCUS.
FOR YOU AS WELL.
WELL ON. IN THERE'S A LOT THAT'S
UNKNOWN ABOUT THE.
BENEFITS OR RISKS OF E.
CIGARETTES AS YET THEY ARE NOT
YET REGULATED. THAT'S BEEN
DELAYED FOR SOMETIME ALTHOUGH
THE AYE IF HE'S GETTING A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
INTERESTED IN A SPECIAL WITH
JEWEL THAT'S BEEN AFFECT
EFFECTING YOUNG PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY THERE'S NOTHING GOOD
ABOUT BEING ADDICTED TO
NICOTINE.
ADULTS OR CHILDREN AND THE
CIGARETTE IS ANOTHER WAY OF
BECOMING ADDICTED TO THIS TODAY
KATANA MY PERSONAL OPINION ON
THIS IS THAT. NOW WE NEED TO
WORK AGAINST THAT CD THE FDA IS
ACTUALLY WORKING TO REDUCE
NICOTINE IN GENERAL DE AS THE
SOURCE OF A CONTINUED SMOKING.
SO THE ONLY OTHER ISSUE I I
THINK IS IS WORTH THINKING ABOUT
IS THAT THE CIGARETTES ARE E.
WASTE. THEY'VE GOT A BATTERY
THEY'VE GOT DOES SOLUTION THAT'S
ACTUALLY POISONOUS.
THAT YOU KNOW OF KIDS WHO GET
INTO IT.
ME IT IS SOMETHING I CAN BE A
RISK AS WELL SO I THINK THAT
THERE ARE SOME DOWNSIDES AS WELL
THE OTHER ISSUES THAT IT'S BEEN
SHOWN THAT THERE'S A LOT OF DUAL
USE. INTO STAINING SMOKING
RATHER THAN AND IT REALLY.
GETTING PEOPLE TO QUIT.
NO ALSO ANOTHER STERN TEST WHERE
THAT.
SOME OF THE OTHER HEALTH
ADVOCACY GROUPS.
SUCH AS AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION ARE CESSATION WORK
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
EYES THAT JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT HERE ARE THEY IN FACT NOT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NO THEY'RE NOT SUPPORTING THE
BILL AT THIS POINT THAT THE
FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA THAT I'VE
BEEN TALKING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO BUT ON THE
NATIONAL LEVEL THEY'RE NOT THERE
YET AND THE REASON IS. IS
BECAUSE THIS WOULD PROMOTE ONE
TYPE OF CIGARETTE OVER ANOTHER
AND FOR NOT BANNING CIGARETTES
ALTOGETHER. THEY'RE NOT
INTERESTED.
WHICH STRIKES ME IN THAT WHOLE
HEALTH DISCUSSION THE JUST SEEMS
INCONCLUSIVE AT BEST.
.
YEAH THAT THAT THE THIRD ISSUE.
THAT COMES TO MIND WAS REYES NOT
DISCUSSION AND WAS ADDRESSED
SOMEWHAT.
WAS THIS QUESTION OF WHETHER OR
NOT FEDERAL LAW PROHIBITS IT
OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE DIFFERENT
OPINIONS ON THAT.
.
WE CERTAINLY.
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCLUSIVE
DIRECTION.
AND.
YOUR FOURTH IN THAT REALLY
CONCERNS HO THE BILL WERE STONE
AND AND DID THE LAST TIME.
WE SAW THIS BILL BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE.
I IS IT JUST SEEMS MISPLACED TO
LAY THE BURDEN.
AT THE DOORSTEP OF THE
RETAILERS.
RATHER THAN THE DOORSTEP OF THE
PERPETRATORS OF THE CRIME WHICH
IS THE LETTERING.
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT I AGREE
WITH WITH THE COMMENTS THAT YOU
SHARED.
REGARDING INCREASED FINES. AND I
WOULD ADD TO THAT ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE I THINK WE ALL AGREE
FINDS ARE ONE THING BUT FINDS
NOT FORCED OR ARE LARGE LUCIOUS
WE HAVE SEEN THE EDUCATION. OF
FINES AND ENFORCEMENT HAVE
HANDSOME SIGNIFICANTLY POSITIVE
IMPACTS AND THERE'S A DRUNK
DRIVING.
AND. IT SEEMS THAT THEY COULD
HAVE A SIMILARLY. A POSITIVE
EFFECTS IF WE WERE TO
DRASTICALLY INCREASE THE FINE
AND AND COUPLE THAT WITH SERIOUS
ENFORCEMENT.
EDUCATION THE SEEMS LIKE WE
COULD MAKE AN IMPACT HIM TO
COMMENT ON THAT YEAH.
POTENTIALLY THAT THE PROBLEM
WITH THIS PARTICULAR CRIME OF
LITTERING AND I'M NOT. I DON'T
KNOW THAT.
RAISING THE THE FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
CIGARETTE.
AND THAT'S POTENTIALLY THOUSAND
DOLLARS SPECIAL OUT OF A MOVING
VEHICLE ESPECIALLY DURING FIRE
SEASON.
LAW ENFORCEMENT NEEDS TO SEE
THAT.
IT'S A VERY QUICK DISTINCT OR OR
SMOKER ON THE BEACH OR IN A PARK
OR ON OUR GROUNDS.
LOOK OUT EFFECTIVE WE ARE TO
FORCING IT ON OUR OWN CAPITAL
GRANTS.
AND THIS IS AN AREA THAT'S
POLICED DAILY.
AND YET WALKER AND NOW IN THE
AFTERNOON AND YOU'LL SEE
CIGARETTE* EVERYWHERE THAT
ACTS
DROPPING IT STEPPING ON IT.
IS POTENTIALLY THOUSAND DOLLAR
FINE DOESN'T SEEM TO IMPACTS.
HERE AND THE WITH ALL THE CHP
AND THE GROUNDS.
CREW AND EVERYONE WHO'S HERE ON
OUR CAPITOL GROUNDS.
THAT ILLEGAL ACTS WITH PLENTY
PEOPLE AROUND TO POTENTIALLY
ENFORCED. DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE
MUCH OF A DIFFERENCE SO WE COULD
SPEND A LOT OF MONEY ON LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE COULD ASK THEM TO GO AND
FORCE.
THE LITTERING LAWS.
DON'T KNOW THAT THAT WOULD GO
OVER VERY WELL NOR DO THEY HAVE
THE RESOURCES FOR ESPECIALLY FOR
SUCH A VERY QUICK DISCRETE ACT
DRUNK DRIVING VERY DIFFERENT
OTHER IMPACTS EDUCATION AND
ENFORCEMENT. SURE CAN WORK
DEPENDING ON THE CRIME.
THIS IS BAD AND AN ONGOING ISSUE
FOR A LONG TIME THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF PUBLIC. OUTREACH IN FACT
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH HAS AN
AD SERIES ABOUT DON'T THROW YOUR
* AWAY AND THAT FOLLOWS A
CIGARETTE* OUT TO THE.
THE GREAT DOWN THE SEWER GRATE
IN AND OUT ON TO THE BEACH.
THEY ALSO SEEM TO BE CHANGING
THE BEHAVIOR OF ESPECIALLY THE
SMALL POPULATION THAT REMAINS
SMOKING.
SO SOMETHING WOULD WORK THERE
I'M OPEN TO MY GOAL HERE IS TO
REDUCE IS TO TO TAKE THE THE
MOST UBIQUITOUS ITEM A TRASH SEE
HOW FAR DOWN THAT LIST WE CAN
PUT IT.
THIS ISN'T AN ATTEMPT
I DO WAY TO DO THAT AGAIN TAKE
THE PRODUCT THAT'S BEING TOSSED
MAKE IT LESS HARMFUL IN THE
ENVIRONMENT IT IS STILL.
IN THIS AN ANALYSIS IT'S STILL
OFFENSIVE.
TOSS EVEN THE FILTER THE
CIGARETTE*.
AND AND THERE MUST BE SOMEBODY
WHO ROLLS AROUND HERE THE
CAPITAL THAT KNOWS ON THE THE
SOUTH SIDE MORE.
TO ME IT'S NOT JOINTS BECAUSE
THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF MATERIAL
INSIDE OF IT.
BUT MORE.
OF OF A FILTER LESS HAND ROLLED
CIGARETTE* THAT THAT ARE OUT
THERE SO THIS IS JUST.
A PATTER.
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A HABIT IT'S
PART OF THE HABIT IT'S.
IT'S A WAY OF LIFE.
WITH THE WORDS CAN HAVE TO.
AGREE TO DISAGREE ON THAT THE
SENSE LIKE.
I BELIEVE IF WE TOOK.
TWENTY CHP OFFICERS AND STARTED
HANDING OUT THOUSAND DOLLAR
FINES BY THE HUNDREDS AND LACKS
COUPLE MONTHS OF ALL THE SUDDEN
THERE'D BE A LOT LESS LETTERING
ON CAPITAL GRANTS.
DEPEND ON ME I WOULD HOPE SO
AND AND I WOULD ENLIST YOUR HELP
WITH CHP TO TO SEE IF THEY WILL
COME BACK. ON. THE END AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
I JUST THINK IT MAKES MORE SENSE
TO START WITH THE PERPETRATOR OF
THE LETTERING THAN IT DOES TO
PLACES BURDEN AT THE DOORSTEP OF
THE RETAILER. I'VE EXPRESSED
THAT TO YOU IN PRIOR DISCUSSIONS
ARE SUBJECT IRAQ REMAINS MY
OPINION.
AND I'D LIKE TO SEE S. AT LEAST
MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION AS A
FIRST STEP IN.
AS WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT UNUSUAL
LETTERING WHICH CERTAINLY THE
GOAL IS SOMETHING.
WE'RE ALL IN AGREEMENT WITH.
ON FOR ALL THOSE REASONS ARE
RECOMMENDING A NO VOTE TODAY ON
ON THE BILL BEFORE US.
DO WE HAVE.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS I BELIEVE
MISTER LEVINE.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU MISTER
STONE FOR THE BILL AND I JUST
WANNA THINK THE ENTIRE
COMMITTEE.
FOR THE THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION
AND
A LOT OF FOR PERSPECTIVES ON
THIS ISSUE WHEN AND HOW TO
APPROACH IT.
AND.
I CERTAINLY HAVE WRESTLED WITH
THAT ISSUE.
IN MY OWN WAY AND THEN OF
COURSE WITHOUT PRIOR BELIEVE
YOUR SITE HAD A BILL OF MINE TO
SPANNING SMOKING ON ON BEACHES
AND PARKS THAT TARA WAS VETOED.
VERY RECENTLY.
JUST LAST MONTH BROUGHT MY
CHILDREN TO YOUR DISTRICT TO OF
THE SENATE CRUZ BOARDWALK.
AND THE FIRST THING MY NINE YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER ASKED ME WAS WHY
ARE THERE SO MANY CIGARETTES
IN THE SAN DAD.
AND I DID HAVE THE HEART TO TELL
HER.
IT'S BECAUSE SIDE THE GOVERNOR
VETOED MY BILL THAT WOULD HAVE
BANNED IT.
THOUGH I
THINK IF I HAVE A CHANCE
INTRODUCED HER TO HIM MAY BE OUT
TELLER. AT THAT POINT IN THE
CHAIN HIM.
FOR WHAT HE DID BUT I THINK THE
CHAIR.
ALSO RAISES SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT POINTS ABOUT HOW WE
POLICE OF THIS TYPE OF LITTER IN
THE CHALLENGES OF ENFORCEMENT.
AND.
IN WHILE WE THINK THAT WE HAVE
THE FORCE THAT WE NEED HERE AT
CAPITOL PARK. AND OF COURSE WITH
ALL THE CAMERAS AND SURVEILLANCE
THAT WE HAVE.
THAT THIS OP PERHAPS COULD BE A
NUISANCE THAT WE RAISE VERY
HIGH.
AND ENFORCE AT EVEN IF WE COULD
DO THAT IF IT WAS A NUISANCE
THAT THAT WENT THAT HIGH. ON NOT
EVERYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA DO WE
HAVE THE SURVEILLANCE AND THE
FORCE TO POLICE IT AT THE LEVEL
THAT WE COULD DREAM THAT WE
COULD DO HERE WE HAVE A LOT OF
OTHER PROBLEMS.
LIKE FIGHTS THAT TAKE PLACE AT
CAPITOL PARK.
THAT OCCURRED IN THE PAST YEAR
THAT WE ALSO NEED TO POLICE
IT'S KIND OF A HIGH NUISANCES
WELL. SO. YOU KNOW IT I'VE
LOOKED AT AT THIS A LOT I HAVE
LISTEN TO THIS DEBATE IN A LOT
OF THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE HEARD.
YOU KNOW REMIND ME OF OF SOME
OTHER YOU KNOW THAT THERE IS
SOME ANALOGIES OF.
HOW WE'VE DEALT WITH EMISSIONS
ON CARS AND THAT WE'VE TRIED TO
REGULATE EMISSIONS ON CARS IN A
DIFFERENT WAY THAT THE SAME
TECHNOLOGY YOU?
SWINGING
OTHER THINGS THAT WERE USED IN
THE PAST AREN'T APPROPRIATE NOW
BECAUSE OF THE HEALTH IMPACTS.
THAT WE I THINK YOU'VE ALSO
BEEN VERY THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THE
IMPACTS ON THE SMOKERS
THEMSELVES THE FIELD OR THE
TASTE.
.
WHICH I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE IN
FACT EXTRAORDINARILY GENEROUS.
TO CONSIDER ADDED THOSE ISSUES
AS MUCH AS THAT BUT YOU'VE HAD.
I THINK OF THE FILTER.
AND IN WHAT CAN BE DONE TO MAKE
SURE SMOKERS KNOW WHAT'S THE
FRONT AND IN THE BACK END OF A
CIGARETTE.
IT'S A SIMPLE AS SIDE THEY DO
WITH RACE CARS.
YOU PUT A STICKER.
HEADLIGHT ON AND YOU PRETEND
THE RACE CAR HAS A HEADLIGHT YOU
CAN MAKE A CIGARETTE LOOK LIKE
IT HAS A FILTER SO SMOKER CAN
FIGURE OUT. WHICH SIDE THEY WANT
TO DRAW FROM.
IF THEY'RE HAVING A HARD TIME
WITH THAT. THERE ARE SOME OTHER
POINTS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
THAT WE DO NEED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK THROUGH.
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW.
PERHAPS OR OTHER WAYS THAT WE
CAN DO ENFORCEMENT.
DATA WE CAN REGULATE AT THE END
OF THE WHOLESALER NOT JUST THE
RETAILER AS WELL. THE
MANUFACTURE COULD BE A POINT AT
WHICH WE ARE WERE WORKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY DON'T COME
INTO. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE CAN BE CREATIVE ABOUT
THOSE APPROACHES SO WE DON'T PUT
TOO MUCH OF A.
AN ONEROUS RESPONSIBILITY I
GUESS ON A RETAILER TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE NOT SELLING THE
WRONG.
PRODUCTS MAYBE LAST YEAR'S MODEL
THAT SOMEHOW MADE IT IN. OF BUT
I DON'T THINK I IF WE CLEAN UP
THE THE PRODUCT STREAM THAT WE
CAN HELP MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
IS FOLLOWING THE LAW.
AS WE ADOPTED AS YOU FINE TUNE
THIS BILL. SO ON I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING THAT TODAY HOPE TO
SUPPORT IT. WHEN I IT COMES ON
TO THE FLOOR SOMEDAY AND I'M
PROUD TO ITS MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
SEEING THAT.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
EVERY MOTION.
A SECOND BUT THEN WE HAVE A
SECOND.
MOTION IS DO PASS.
TO ASSEMBLY HELPED.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY NO GRAY NO BIGELOW. BIGELOW
NO ACOSTA NO ACOSTA NO I WHERE
CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY ABSTAINING.
BERMAN.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY NO COOPER.
DALY.
DALY NOT VOTING. GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE.
KILEY.
KILEY NO LACKEY.
LACKEY NO LIVING.
LIVING AYE LOW.
RUBIO.
SOLIS.
WALDRON.
WALDRON NO.
THAT BILL HAS THREE VOTES YOU
NEED EIGHT WILL LEAVE THE ROLL
UP.
THANK YOU MISTER THEY WERE
STUCK.
OKAY.
MEMBERS AT THIS POINT.
WE HAVE TWO PRESENTATIONS LEFT.
MR LOW AND MISTER MURATSUCHI.
.
SEEING NEITHER WILL GO AHEAD AND
I GIVE THEM FIVE MINUTES OR SO
TO GET TO COMMITTEE.
AND THEN WILL ADJOURNMENT.
NO.
SEE MR LOW. COME ON UP IN.
PRESENT YOUR ITEM.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS IS I ITEM
SEVEN ON YOUR AGENDA AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY NINE LOW.
SIR PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS AYE
DECLARING JUNE AS LGBT PRIDE
MONTH THIS SIMPLY CODIFIES THIS.
IN STATUTE AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO A RECOGNIZE A
NUMBER OF VARIOUS CONSTITUENCY
GROUPS.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AND AT
PASSED VARIOUS RESOLUTIONS AT
THE SIMPLY NOT AS MUCH AS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
ANY TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
TRIGGERING MEISTER BUT. MY NAME
IS DAVID HEIZER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SACRAMENT OF THE
BG COMMUNITY CENTER AND WE OTHER
PRODUCERS OF SACRAMENTO PRIDE
PARADE AND FESTIVAL.
PRIDE DIDN'T START OUT AS THE
CELEBRATION IT REALLY BEGAN WITH
A REVOLUTION WHERE. TRANSGENDER
WOMEN OF COLOR AND DRAG QUEENS
HAD HAD ENOUGH OF THE HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION POLICE RAIDS AND
BEATINGS THAT THEY EXPERIENCED.
.
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY AND STOOD UP
AND IN A RYAN.
IN THE NEARLY FIFTY YOUR SENSE
PRIDE IS INVOLVED BEYOND MERE
PROTEST AGAINST DISCRIMINATION
AND VIOLENCE.
TO TAKE A POSITIVE STANCE THE
PROMOTE SELF AFFIRMATION DIGNITY
AND EQUAL RIGHTS.
PRIDE AS OPPOSED TO SHAME
SYMBOLIZES HOPE FOR A MORE
EQUITABLE AND JUST FUTURE ACROSS
THE WORLD.
DESPITE THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE
OVER THE MANY DECADES YOUNG
CALIFORNIA WE ARE CONTINUE TO BE
UNDER TALK ABOUT FEDERAL LEVEL
AND EVERY YEAR IS STILL
EXPERIENCING HERE FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHO ATTEND THEIR
VERY FIRST PRIDE.
AND FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
FEEL FREE AND OPEN ABOUT WHO
THEY ARE.
FOR THE FIRST TIME THEY
RECOGNIZE THEM IN THEMSELVES IN
THE PEOPLE THAT THEY SEE AROUND
THEM PUSHING A STROLLER SHARING
A MEAL WITH THE PARTNER. PLAYING
WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
I HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT BUYING A HOUSE TOGETHER OR
SEEKING SERVICES IN AFFIRMING
Y..
SUPPORT OF THEIR COMMUNITY GIVES
THEM THE CONFIDENCE TO CONTINUE
LIVING AUTHENTICALLY WHEN THEY
EXIT THE POSSIBLE THAT DAY. IN A
WAY THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE NO LONGER
ALONE IN THE WORLD.
THEIR WELCOME IN OUR STATE IN
THAT IT'S POSSIBLE FOR THEM TO
THRIVE.
PRIDE MONTH IS NO MORE MORE THAN
JUST THE GLITTER AND RAINBOWS OF
TRADE FLOATS.
I CLEARING THE ALL ARE WELCOME
HERE YEAR ROUND.
YOU KNOW I ENJOY A LOT OF
PRIVILEGES THE WAYS THE CENTER
MAN.
THROUGH ITS EASIER FOR ME TO
CELEBRATE PRIDE EVERYDAY BUT
LGBTQ PEOPLE ARE ALSO BLACK AND
BROWN AND IMMIGRANTS AND WOMEN
AND.
OTHER PEOPLE OF FAITH
SO.
SO I URGE YOU TO PURCHASE MORE
THIS BILL AND TO MAKE PRIDE.
THEN IT'S A PERMANENT THING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOE MICHAEL
FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS TIME
YOU'VE HEARD WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT AND AND THAT'S REALLY
JUST WOULD MAKE IT SO THAT THE
GOVERNOR NEEDS TO RECOGNIZE
JUNE.
AUTOMATICALLY EVERY YEAR AND
REFLECT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO MAKE TO CALIFORNIA
SO URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL LA TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY ADDITIONS OR ANY
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING THAT WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL DO WE. WE HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND THIS IS DUE PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
OKAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
ACOSTA.
I WHERE CURRY.
I WHERE CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOPER I'VE COOPER IDEALLY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER ARE.
JONES SAWYER AYE
KILEY.
LACKEY IF YOU.
RUBIO AYE SO THIS.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THAT BILLS ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOOK.
OKAY EITHER.
MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO ITEM ONE ON YOUR AGENDA
THIS IS AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO.
I SEE MISTER MURATSUCHI MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE WELCOME AND
PLEASE.
.
APPROACH A PRESENTER ITEM.
WELCOME GENTLEMEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO.
ALONG WITH OUR MAJORITY LEADER
MISTER CALDERON.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT.
THERE IS NO MORE SPORT THERE'S
MORE ICONIC.
THE CALIFORNIA THAT THE SPORT OF
SURFING.
WELL CALIPHAL WHILE SURFING IS.
ORIGINALLY THE SPORT OF HAWAIIAN
ROYALTY.
THERE IS SO MUCH OF A PROUD
HERITAGE AND.
.
CLEARLY THE IMAGE OF CALIFORNIA
IS ALL ABOUT SURFING.
WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS.
.
TOURISM AND RECREATION INDUSTRY
A COASTAL ECONOMY THAT IS BASED
ON SURFING.
SURFING IS ALSO.
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT WITH
GROUPS LIKE THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION.
SUSTAINABLE SURF AND OTHERS
THAT.
.
HAVE.
EMPHASIZE
AND CHAMPION THE MASSES OF
PROTECTING THE OCEAN IN
PROTECTING OUR COAST.
AND SO I BELIEVE THAT IT IS
APPROPRIATE.
FOR CALIFORNIA TO DECLARE
SURFING AS OUR OFFICIAL SPORT.
THIS IS A SPORT THAT IS NOT
JUST FOR OUR COASTAL DISTRICTS.
I AM PROUD TO HAVE FOR EXAMPLE
MISTER SALAS.
AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR.
OR HE REPRESENTS AMONG OTHERS.
THE CITY OF LAMAR WHICH HAS.
THE FIRST.
MAN MADE AND ACCORDING TO.
OUR REAL SURFER HERE MISTER
CALDERON.
ONE OF THE BEST WORLD IN ONE OF
THE BEST WAVES IN THE WORLD.
THAT.
IS GOING TO SPREAD SURFING FROM
THE COAST.
THROUGHOUT THE CITY CALIFORNIA.
SO I'D LIKE TO TURN OVER TWO OF
MISTER CALDERON. THAT'S TALK
ABOUT.
Y. SURFING ISN'T IS SO IMPORTANT
TO HIM.
MAKE YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SO I GREW UP SURFING
THIS MY LIFE I STARTED WHEN I
WAS SEVEN YEARS OLD AND MY FIRST
SPONSOR WHEN I WAS TEN YEARS OLD
COMPETED. STATE CHAMPION AND TWO
THOUSAND SIX A LOOSER FOR
COLLEGE.
MY COLLEGE LONG BEACH STATE.
AND.
YOU KNOW WE THINK OF CALIFORNIA
TO GIVE A COUPLE THINGS YOU
THINK OF DISNEYLAND.
THINK OF HOLLYWOOD.
YOU THINK OF NO MAYBE NOT THAT
BUT.
YOU THINK OF THE OUR
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY THINK A
SURFING AND IT'S JUST ONE OF
THOSE SPORTS MORE THAN ANY OTHER
SPORT IN THE STATE ARE
SYNONYMOUS WITH THE STATE.
AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ARE WRAPPED UP IN THE
ECONOMY WE HAVE.
.
OVER A THOUSAND MILES OF
BEAUTIFUL CLOTHES LINE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT EACH
AND EVERY YEAR WE SPEND TIME AND
TIME AGAIN EFFORT EFFORT AGAIN
TO TRY TO KEEP CLEAN TRY TO KEEP
YOUR.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF LOCAL
ECONOMIES IT DEPENDS VERY MUCH
ON THIS INDUSTRY THERE'S WERE.
SERVE.
CONTEST THAT HAPPEN UP AND DOWN
THE STATE THAT GENERATE A LOT OF
MONEY FOR LOCAL ECONOMIES AND AS
MY COLLEAGUE JUST TALKED ABOUT
WE HAVE.
ARGUABLY NOW THE BEST WAY IN
THE WORLD I WE'VE ALWAYS HAD
SOME BROKE WORLD CLASS WAYS WHAT
IS NORTH NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
FROM SANTA CRUZ YOU KNOW THE TO
SEND THIS BEST MALL THE WAY DOWN
THROUGH SECOND MANY ORANGE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO I HAVE AT THE
VERY TOP OF OUR STATE.
BUT WE HAVE WHAT IS NOW THE
BEST WAY IN THE WORLD WHICH IS
IN IN FARMLAND THAT'S IN FARM
COUNTRY.
IT'S IN THE MORE CALIFORNIA AND
IT'S CALLED THE SERVE FRENCH
WHERE THIS WEEK IN IRAQ I
RECOMMEND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
YOU CHECK IT OUT. AYE IT'S GOING
TO BE LIVE EVENT FOR YOU GUYS TO
CHECK OUT ON THE WSL DOT COM THE
WORLD'S OUR FLEET DOT COM.
S. SURFING EVENT HAPPENING IN
CENTRAL RURAL CALIFORNIA.
THE BEST WAVE IN THE WORLD. AND
IT'S GOING TO BE A WORLD EVENT
WHERE YOU HAVE DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES THE UNITED STATES
AUSTRALIA BRAZIL WORLD TEAM THAT
ARE ALL GOING TO BE COMPETING
AGAINST EACH OTHER FOR A WORLD
CUP. AND THIS IS THE PRECURSOR
FOR THE OLYMPICS.
I THIS IS WHERE THE OLYMPIC
COMMITTEE CAME TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
TO ACTUALLY WITNESS WHAT THIS
WAY PEOPLE CAN DO.
AND THIS IS A THAT IT A SERVING
IS GONNA BE INTRODUCED INTO THE
OLYMPICS BY TWENTY TWENTY
SERVING AS AN OFFICIAL OLYMPIC
SPORT. IT'S GOING TO BE HELD IN
JAPAN AN ACTUAL OPEN OCEAN BUT
THE FUTURE OF THE SPORT IN
SPECIFICALLY OLYMPIC ASIDE OF
THE SPORT IS GOING TO BE. ON
DISPLAY WHICH OLYMPIC COMMITTEE
HAS OR TO COME OUT TO SEE BUT
IT'S GOING TO BE THERE AGAIN
OUGHT TO SEE THIS WEEKEND IN THE
MORE CALIFORNIA SO I I RECOMMEND
YOU GUYS ALL CHECK OUT IT'S
PRETTY COOL.
BUT AGAIN YOU HAVE.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WRAPPED UP
IN THIS ECONOMY WITH THIS WITH
THIS.
SPORT IN ITS ONLY FITTING.
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE A STATE
DINOSAUR WE HAVE STATE NOT. WE
HAVE A LOT OF STATE THINGS.
BUT WE NEED A STATE WE NEED THE
STATE'S BOARD THAT'S BORDEAUX.
IS. IS ABSOLUTELY.
US IT IN POSITIVELY IT SHOULD
BE SURFING AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE WE
WERE TRYING TO GET KELLY SLATER
TO BE OUR. OUR OF MAIN WITNESS
TODAY BUT THAT WE DID EVEN
BETTER WE HAVE JENNIFER SAVAGE
WITH THE SURFRIDER FOUNDATION.
AND MICHAEL STEWART WITH
SUSTAINABLE SIR.
RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GRAY AND
DISTINGUISH COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL STEWART HOW
ON THE FOUNDER OF SUSTAINABLE
SURF ENVIRONMENT NONPROFIT BASED
IN MANHATTAN BEACH AND. I'M
MARIN COUNTY.
THE HISTORY OF SERVING IS CLEAR
SURFING WAS INVENTED BY
POLYNESIAN PEOPLES SEVERAL
THOUSAND YEARS AGO.
AND WAS BROUGHT TO HIGH ART FORM
IN THE HAWAIIAN ISLANDS.
SERVING HELD NOT ONLY A DEEP
CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE TO THEM AS
THE NATIONAL PASTIME BUT HAD ITS
PLACE IN RELIGION AND EVEN LOCAL
POLITICS TO. AT SOME AGENTS
SURFING COMPETITIONS DETERMINE
WHO OR WHO WOULD NOT STAND POWER
SO. THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
WE COULD TRY HERE'S WELL.
.
SO IT'S FITTING THAT SERVING IS
ALREADY THE STATE'S FOR.
OF WHO I AND WE LOOK UPON THAT
AS AN INSPIRATION.
FOR THE EFFORT TO DESIGNATE
SERVING AS THE OFFICIAL STATE
SUPPORT A CALIFORNIA.
SO WHAT IS CALIFORNIA DESERVED
THAT HONOR
WHERE'S Y..
THE HISTORY OF SURFING ANYWHERE
IN THE WORLD OUTSIDE OF THE
HAWAIIAN ISLANDS BEGINS ON A HOT
SUMMER DAY IN JULY. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE
IN THE SMALL TOWN OF SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA WERE THREE HAWAIIAN
PRINCES. NAMED DAVID EDWARD AND
JONAH SPARK THE IMAGINATION AND
INNOVATION OF EARLY
CALIFORNIANS.
BY WRITING THEIR LOCALLY BUILT
SURFBOARDS.
CRAFTED FROM NATIVE REDWOOD
TREES.
WHICH BY THE WAY JUST HAPPEN TO
BE THE OFFICIAL STATE TREE
CALIFORNIA.
BEFORE AN ADORING AND IN A MAYES
CROWD.
AN AUSPICIOUS START INDEED TO
THE BEGINNING OF SERVE CULTURE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT EARLY SPARK IGNITED A
FIRE OF INNOVATION.
HEADQUARTERED RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS SPREAD SUPPORT SERVING
TO THE FURTHEST REACHES OF THE
GLOBE.
AND AS BILL A SERVING INDUSTRY
WORTH OVER TEN BILLION DOLLARS
AND GROWING EVERY YEAR.
SO CONSIDER THIS VERY SHORT LIST
OF CALIFORNIA BASED INNOVATIONS
THAT SPREAD THE CULTURE OF
SURFING AND OF CALIFORNIA.
AROUND THE WORLD.
THE WORLD'S FIRST AIRPORT
FACTORY LOS ANGELES THE WORLD'S
FIRST RETAIL SURF SHOP SAN
FRANCISCO.
THE INVENTION OF NEOPRENE RUBBER
RIGHT HIM AND IN BERKELEY
INVENTION OF WET SUITS AND
SENATORS.
THE INVENTION OF SIR FORECASTING
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S SCRIPTS INSTITUTION
OF OCEANOGRAPHY IN SAN DIEGO.
THE INVENTOR OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST ECO SURFBOARD
MANUFACTURING MATERIALS.
SUCH AS PLANT BASED RESINS IN
HAYWARD AND RECYCLE EPS FORMER
IRVINE AND LASTLY. AND THE
INVENTION OF THE WORLD'S FIRST
HIGH PERFORMANCE ARTIFICIAL
SURFING WAVE LOOK AT IT RIGHT
THERE IN CALIFORNIA'S.
HOW CENTRAL VALLEY IN?
LA MORE AND BEING.
SUSTAINABLY POWER BY P. GENIES
GREEN POWER PROGRAM WHICH IS
HOSTING ITS FIRST PUBLIC WORLD
CLASS COMPETITION THIS WEEKEND
THAT WILL BE THE OUR BLUEPRINT
FOR INTRODUCING SURFING. AS THE
OFFICIAL SPORT IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY OLYMPICS.
SO WHILE SURFING WAS INVENTED IN
HAWAII AND BROUGHT TO AN ART
FORM THERE.
CALIFORNIA SURF CULTURE HAS BEEN
CONTINUALLY REINVENTING THE
STATE OF THE ART OF THE SPORT.
OF SURFING FOR THE LAST ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE YEARS. AS
TURN IN OBSCURE PASTIME FROM A
FAR AWAY PLACE INTO A GLOBAL
OBSESSION.
AND A POWERFUL AND POSITIVE
ECONOMIC ENGINE FOR GOOD EFFORT
AND THAT'S WHY SERVING SHOULD BE
THE OFFICIAL STATE SUPPORT.
OF THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREETINGS UNABLE CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER SAVAGE IN
CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER WITH
THE SURFRIDER FOUNDATION
SURFRIDER HAS TWENTY CHAPTERS UP
AND DOWN THE CALIFORNIA COAST
FROM CRESCENT CITY OF NEAR THE
OREGON BORDER DOWN TO SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
AND AS WELL AS BEING DEDICATED
TO THE PROTECTION OF THE WORLD'S
OCEAN BEACHES AND WAVES WE ARE
AS ENSHRINED IN OUR MISSION
STATEMENT ALSO DEDICATED TO THE
ENJOYMENT OF THEM. AND NOTHING
SPEAKS TO THE ENJOYMENT OF%
CALIFORNIA'S OCEAN BEACHES IN
WAVES AS MUCH AS THE ICONIC
SPORT OF SURFING. TO BUILD ON
WHAT MICHAEL SAID FROM THE TIME
HAWAIIANS INTRODUCED SURFING IN
CALIFORNIA ARE STATES RESIDENTS
HAVE ADDED INVALUABLE ADVANCES
TO THE SPORT. THE SURF INDUSTRY
IN ORANGE COUNTY IS WHAT THE
TECH INDUSTRY IS TO SILICON
VALLEY.
THE ABILITY TO PROTECT SWELLS
THAT CAME OUT OF SCRIPTS IN THE
PLAYER GAVE RISE TO THE GLOBAL
PHENOMENON OF SURFLINE WHICH IS
HEADQUARTERED IN HUNTINGTON
BEACH.
ALSO IN THE SCIENCE SPENCER
FIGHTERS CURRENTLY PARTICIPATING
IN A PILOT PROJECT USING SMART
FANS TO DETECT OCEAN CHANGE AND.
SAN DIEGO AND LOS ANGELES.
FURTHER NORTH THE EPIC WAVES OF
SANTA CRUZ INSPIRED AND
INNOVATION KNOWN AS THE WET SUIT
WHICH IS A LIFE CHANGING
INVENTION IF YOU'RE LIKE ME
YOU'RE CLOSER REDWOODS AND YOU
DO PALM TREES.
IN HIS TWENTY SIXTEEN PULITZER
PRIZE WINNING THEM WIRE WILLIAM
FINNEGAN REALLY BRILLIANT AT THE
TALES OF SURFING SAN FRANCISCO'S
OCEAN BEACH. AND EVEN REMOTE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY. YOU CAN FIND
NEWSPAPER CLIPPINGS OF THE
AREA'S FIRST SURF CONTESTS WHICH
TOOK PLACE IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE. I THE WILD RUGGED LOST
COAST.
WE EVEN HAVE KELLY SLATER'S MAY
PULL IN THE MORNING WITHOUT
WHICH A LOT HAS BEEN SAID AND IT
IS REALLY EXCITING THAT WERE
HAVING A WORLD CLASS THEIR
CONTEST IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I LIKE
BEST ABOUT SURFING.
IF IT AS IT IS AT HEART A
DEMOCRATIC SPORT THAT REFLEXIS
SPIRIT OF THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
ACT.
THE OCEAN LIKE CALIFORNIA'S
BEACHES BELONGS TO EVERYONE.
MY WORK TAKES ME ALL OVER THE
COAST OF CERTAIN NEARLY EVERY
COASTAL COUNTY AND STILL WORKING
ON CINNAMON SANTA BARBARA. AND
LA EVERY FREAK EVERY PLACE HAS
ITS UNIQUE CHARACTERISTICS THE
JOY OF BEING IN THE WATER IS THE
SAME EVERYWHERE.
SERVINGS APPEAL RESONATES WITH
PEOPLE FROM ALL DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS REGARDLESS OF INCOME
AND GENDER OR SKIN COLOR.
FURTHER SURFING BRINGS PEOPLE
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD TO OUR
COAST THE EXPERIENCE IN
COASTAL ECONOMY WHICH IS VALUED
AT FORTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
EVERY SUMMER FAMILIES FROM
INLAND AREAS PACK UP THE KIDS
AND HEAD TO THE BEACH HOPPING TO
THE WAYS WITH CAMMY DOWN BOARDS
FROM UNCLE'S NEIGHBOR IS BIG
SISTERS. SHARING THE STOVE AS
IT'S KNOWN IS A TIME HONORED
TRADITION IN THE SURF COMMUNITY.
AN ESTIMATED TWO MILLION
AMERICANS SERVED IN OVER HALF OF
THOSE LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN SHORT FROM OUR CULTURE TO OUR
ECONOMY SURFING IS FULLER
INTERWOVEN AND ARE STATES PAST
PRESENT AND FUTURE.
AND SUB ON BEHALF OF THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION AND THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WE REPRESENT WE
HOPE THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA WARNER BEHALF OF LACKEY
IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
OUR BASEBALL FOLKS SOCCER FANS.
SEE NO. TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
TO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS SHOULD
THE MEMBERS MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING US FOR.
YOU PROBABLY CAN TELL THERE ARE
A WHOLE LOT OF SURFERS AT MY
DISTRICT.
IF I COULD CHANGE ENTITLEMENTS
AND I HOPE YOU WOULD. LOOK INTO
THAT.
.
YOU KNOW I I I. I PRIDE MYSELF
ONE DO A LOT OF SOCCER PLAYERS
IN AND HAVING LOST IS A FOOTBALL
CLUB IN THE BEST. SOCCER STADIUM
IN THE NATION RIGHT NOW.
SO.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT MAKE SURE
THAT. EVERYBODY IS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE NOT A TRULY DO MEAN
THAT AND SO WHATEVER WE CAN DO.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS BILL.
.
TO INCREASED PARTICIPATION OF
ALL SPORTS ON FROM ALL
COMMUNITIES IS IT REALLY
IMPORTANT.
AND.
.
A OF SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
AND.
.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET SOME
DISCUSSION ON HOW.
I SAY WE CAN INTEGRATE THE SPORT
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
OKAY.
THANK.
THIS AYE RECORD.
SO THAT LA TIMES ON ARTICLE NOT
ILONGGO. THE SAYS OF
SKATEBOARDING NOT SURFING SHOULD
BE CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIAL STATE
SUPPORT ANY COMMENTS.
I LOVE SKATEBOARDING. AYE GROUP
SKATEBOARDIN AND I SORT OF
SKATEBOARDING BEFORE I EVER
STARTED SERVING IN AND SO I
THINK THAT SKATEBOARDING
DESERVES AS PROPER RESPECT.
BUT AGAIN WHEN YOU THINK A
STATE OF CALIFORNIA GENERALLY
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW OUR
IDENTITY IN PEOPLE'S PERCEPTION
OF THE IDENTITY OF CALIFORNIANS
ARE.
SPORTS THAT DOES COME UP IS
SURFING ABOUT SKATEBOARDING I
THINK SERVING IS MORE IS MORE.
EMBLEMATIC OF OUR STATE AND OF
OUR CULTURE AND AND AND IF
YOU'LL SO MUCH MORE BECAUSE IT
NOT ONLY IS A HUGE ECONOMIC
DRIVER BUT IT ALSO SPEAKS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT A LOT AND THEY THEY
TAKE ON A LOT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
CAUSES THAT WOULD MATTER A LOT
OF CALIFORNIANS. AND THEY'RE IN
THE CONVERSATION IT IT IS A LOT
BIGGER THAN JUST THE SPORT
ITSELF AND AND IMPACTS A LOT
MORE THAN JUST. THAN JUST PEOPLE
HAVING FUN AND THERE'S LOT OF
ECONOMIC IMPACTS IN THOSE LOT OF
ENVIRONMENTS ON TAXES SO THAT'S
WHAT WE DO BELIEVE. THAT SERVING
IS MORE APPROPRIATE.
MR SHARE IT ON THE WITNESS WOULD
LIKE TO WITH YOUR PERMISSION
SHOOK MY HAND LIKE A RESPONSE TO
THE SKATEBOARDING AMENDMENT AS
PROPOSED BY THIS AMERICA.
I JUST WANNA TAKE KNOWLEDGE AND
BRIEFLY THAT I DON'T I DON'T
SKATEBOARD AFRAID TO FALL DOWN
ON HARD SURFACES BUT I ADMIRE
PEOPLE THAT DO THAT
SKATEBOARDING WAS ACTUALLY
INVENTED BY CALIFORNIA SURFERS
WHO ARE LOOKING. FOR SOMETHING
TO DO WHEN THAT WAS TOO FLAT TO
SURF AND SO THEY TOOK
ROLLERSKATING WHEELS AND GLUE
THEM TO THE BOTTOM OF PLANKS
CITY KID. SIMULATES SURFINGON
LAND SO SKATEBOARDING DOES TIE
BACK TO THE HISTORY OF SURFING
IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY DON'T MISTER CHAIR IF I IF
I CAN GO BACK AND ANSWER MISTER
JONES SAWYER IS CONCERNED
CERTAIN.
IT THERE THERE IS A. YOU KNOW.
MYSELF AND MISTER CALDERON ARE
EXAMPLES OF HOW THERE IS GROWING
DIVERSITY AND THE SPORT OF
SURFING.
THERE'S ALSO A WONDERFUL GROUP
IN. IN OAKLAND.
CALLED A BROWN GIRL SIR.
AND.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET THEM TO
ADD TO THAT TESTIFIED TODAY ALSO
BUT.
.
THERE'RE PROBABLY SURFING.
BUT.
YOU.
YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN.
WE WANT TO SHARE THE LOVE OF
THE OCEAN AND OF SURFING.
WITH ALL COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
KNOW LAIKA MISTER CALDERON SAID
I THINK A FUNDAMENTAL PART OF
SURFING IS WHEN YOU LOVE THE
OCEAN. YOU WANT PROTECTED AND IS
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL MESSAGE.
THAT DISTINGUISHES SURFING FROM
SKATEBOARDING OR ANY OF THE
SPORT.
IT IT IT IS EXCESSIVE ON I WILL
SAY IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
GET OUT HIS BROTHER'S GUYS THAT
I GREW UP WITH GUYS THAT I
COMPETE AGAINST ONE OF THEM WAS
ON A WORLD TOUR RIGHT NOW.
WHO WAS ACTUALLY IN THE MORE
CALIFORNIA ALL THIS WEEK THEY GO
TO SOUTH AFRICA THEY GOT A LOT
OF OTHER PLACES THAT BILL GET UP
THE BUNDLE LIKE? ANYWHERE
BETWEEN THIRTY TO FIFTY
SURFBOARDS TO TAKE A LOOK KIDS
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
UP ALL AROUND THE WORLD AND
ALSO IN THIS COUNTRY TO DO SO.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD WILL AND
YOU KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES AND I KNOW TO TALK
ABOUT. WHAT THEY'RE THERE ARE
EFFORTS BUT YOU KNOW AGAIN YOUR
POINT IS WELL TAKEN WHEN I SEE
BROTHERS ONBOARD?
WE'RE GOOD.
I DO ASK YOU I DO ASK YOU TO TO
GOOGLE MY GOOD FRIEND SAL
MASEKELA AGAIN I WILL.
SO FAR WE HAVE THE SKATEBOARDING
AMENDMENT THE BROTHERS ON BOARDS
AMENDMENT.
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO MISS
WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND.
DOES THAT REALLY BRAVE UP AS YOU
CAN TELL WITH MY NEW YORK ACCENT
GREW UP IN THE CITY. BUT WHEN I
MOVED TO CALIFORNIA MET MY
HUSBAND IS A NATIVE CALIFORNIA
SURFER. AND.
SO I SPENT MANY WEEKEND THAT
DIVERS AND SWAMI ISN'T TRESTLES
AND ALL THOSE PLACES HAVE MY
OWN.
.
THE WHOLE ENSEMBLE ON BOOTIES
AND.
IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE EVEN IN OUR
ENGAGEMENT PHOTO THERE'S US AND
THEN THE SIR FORUMS OF PEOPLE OR
IS IT WILL LOSE THE REALLY
MARRYING BETTER COURT.
SO.
WHEN THIS BILL WAS INTRODUCED A
CAME ON THE RADIO DOWN IN SAN
DIEGO AND MY HUSBAND CALLED ME
UP HERE. ARE YOU GONNA CHO
AUTHOR THIS BLL SO. I TOLD HIM
I WOULD AND IF YOU WOULD ALLOW
ME TO BE A CALL AND WE WOULD BE
HONORED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER BIGELOW.
YES.
MISTER MAYOR CITY.
TO GIVE US A COUPLE OF ASK FOR.
AMENDMENTS HERE AND.
WE HAD ACT.
CONVERSATION.
A REAL IN THEM.
YEAH I RECOGNIZING THE HISTORY.
CALDERON.
RELATED THAT
KILLER ISSUE.
WE LOOK AT IT
ACTUALLY WRITE THE THREE
PRINCESSES.
GREAT STORY
HOW THEY CAME OVER AN EIGHT.
PRIOR TO THAT
RODEOS.
IN THE VERY BEGINNING OF THE
EIGHTEEN.
AND WE'RE RIGHT HERE AT THE
STATE CAL.
AND THEIR ORIGINS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY FROM CALIFORNIA.
MUCH LIKE THE.
HAWAIIAN TECHNIQUES OF.
SURFING.
ARE REALLY NOT THE REAL ORIGINS
YOU ACTUALLY COME FROM. EARLIER
DAYS IN TAHITI
SO WHAT WE RECOGNIZE HOW THIS IS
MORE OF BUT CALIFORNIA'S BECOME
AN EPICENTER AND RODEOS ARE ONE
OF THE KEY. COMPONENTS TO A
SUCCESSFUL SPORTS VENTURE IN.
THE WESTERN WAY OF LIFE RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU CAN'T
GET TO THE NATIONAL FINALS
WITHOUT GOING THROUGH
CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD BE INTERESTED IF YOU
WOULD SERIOUSLY CONSIDER.
AND AMENDMENT RECOGNIZING. THE
RODEO LIGHTEN.
THE RODEO SKILLS.
AND THEY'RE TIED TOGETHER.
BECAUSE THEY BOTH HAVE ONE
COMMENT DAY.
YOU HAVE TO HANG ON.
OKAY AND I WILL SAY THAT WE WERE
DESIGNATED AS THE STATE'S POOR
BUT THERE'S ALSO DESIGNATIONS
THAT YOU CAN DO INDIVIDUAL
SPORTS IN TEAM SPORTS.
TALK TO TOM WE GOT THAT BUT I
FUNDS MIGHT BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO WORK TOGETHER.
I IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING ALSO
THAT THERE ARE STATES THAT HAVE.
MORE THAN ONE OFFICIAL SPORT I
DON'T WANT TO. MAKE ANY
SUGGESTIONS BUT THE.
AS THE COMMITTEE MAY REMEMBER A
CERTAIN FIND LEGSLATOR FROM THE
SAME WORKING DOUBLY. CAME BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE WITH ONE STATE
NOT.
AND WALKED OUT WITH FOUR
STATEMENTS HAVE NOT.
THIS IS A MATTER OF HISTORICAL
INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY.
FOR THOSE THAT ARE NEW TO THE
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE.
THE QUESTION FOR MR CUP.
YEAH.
.
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE.
BEACH VOLLEYBALL PLAYERS ARE
GOING TO HAVE A.
NOT THAT I'M BLIND IT AND
CERTAINLY CANCER BODY CERTAINLY
DOES THAT COUNT BUT UNLIKE
SERIOUSLY.
THAT'S ALL I'M GOOD FOR.
JUST LAYING DOWN AND BODY
SERVERS BODY BOARDERS ALL
CONSIDERED SURFING OKAY VERY
GOOD SO I I THINK I'D LIKE TO
ADD. A VOLLEY. SOFTBALL SOCCER.
THE FOOTBALL AND.
BASEBALL WOMEN FORGETTING
BASKETBALL THE SUPER MALL IN
THERE BUT SURFING IS DEFINITELY
ICONIC FOR CALIFORNIA DON'T
FORGET THE SNOWBOARDERS WHICH IS
WHERE YOU GUYS GO IN THE WINTER
WRITING. SO WE CAN'T FORGET
THAT.
OUR FRIENDS UP IN AMOUNTS BUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET LET A
GREAT SPORTS.
MR LEVINE.
AT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THINKS
RECOUNTING THE.
THAT THE FOR STATE THAT'S THAT
WE'VE GOT BECAUSE I WAS I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THAT
AND HOW WE'RE.
INCLUSIVE. IF YOU WILL NOT BUT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SURFING BEING
THE STATE'S. WE'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT PROTECTING OUR
COAST.
WE'RE TALK ABOUT PROTECTING THE
WATERWAYS WERE TALK NOT KEEPING
IT CLEAN.
.
YOU KNOW THE
EXTRAORDINARY ENVIRONMENTAL
ECOSYSTEM IMPACTS THAT ARE GOOD
FOR ALL OF US.
AND I THINK THAT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT SURFING AS A STATE SPORT
WE ALSO AS WAS TALK ABOUT WAS
THAT A MESSAGE OF INCLUSION.
BEST SURFING IS A SPORT FOR
EVERYONE AND THAT. THE BEACH IS
FOR ALL OF US.
AND WE MUST COMMIT TO DO ALL WE
CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS ACCESS TO OUR
BE.
OUR BEACHES TO OUR COASTS
AND TO THE SPORT OF SURFING AS
WELL AND THAT.
IT HOWEVER WE CAN.
MAKE SURE THAT THAT SPORT IS
INFUSED WITH INCLUSION AND
ACCEPTANCE OF NEW PEOPLE COMING
TO THE BEACH TO SURF.
YOU KNOW.
IT WOULD BE A REALLY GOOD THING
WE WE HEAR TIME AND AGAIN ABOUT
DIFFERENT SPOTS WHO WHERE THE
LOCALS ARE PEOPLE THAT KNOW THAT
ONE SPOT. DON'T WANT THE PEOPLE
THERE.
AND THAT IS THE THE LEAST.
PROBABILITY THE LEAST
REPRESENTATIVE ATTITUDE OF OF
WHAT A TRUE SIR FOR IS.
AND AS MUCH AS WE CAN PUT THAT
OUT THERE THAT SURFING IS FOR
EVERYONE AND EVERYONE IS WELCOME
IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
BILL.
YEAH AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
A LOT OF MONEY TO DO IT IMMINENT
THREE OTHER THAN A STATE.
TO GO AND SERVE.
EIGHT YOU ANYBODY SO TO BE TOO
BIG TO DO AND YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
SUPPORTED ONE OF I SUPPORT WHAT
YOU THAT'S EXPENSIVE.
BUT I THINK RELATIVELY TO THE
OTHER SPORTS IT'S A LOT LESS
EXPENSIVE AND IT'S IT'S ACTION
YOU CAN BORROW AND YOU CAN RENT.
YOU KNOW TO LEARN IT AND SETS IT
BUT I THINK THAT THE POINT
REALLY I WANT TO MAKE IS.
IF WE'RE PUSHIN THE SPORT AS
SOMETHING THAT'S THE STATE.
SPORT RECOGNIZED SOMETHING FOR
MARKETING.
ABOUT HOW GREAT CALIFORNIA IS
IN IT'S TRUE.
THAT IT GETS DOWN TO EVERY
INDIVIDUAL SURFER THAT THEIR
BEACH
IT'S FOR EVERYBODY.
YEAH ALTHOUGH I HAVE A.
ONE OF THE.
NOTORIOUS SPEECH IS.
IN IN MY DISTRICT WILL NOT OBEY.
THERE IS A A GANG OF SURFERS
DILLON ON BAY BOYS THAT.
.
WELL I I HEAR THAT THEY'RE
BUILDING GO. TRYING TO REBUILD
THEIR FORD.
BACK.
PALS VERITIES COAST BETTER.
YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT MITCHELL
BEING THE MAIN.
WE NEED TO.
SHARE THE OCEAN SHARE THE
BEAUTY WITH.
WITH EVERYONE AND THAT INCLUDES.
OPENING UP THE THAT THE SPORTS
ARE FOR.
WE HAD A NUMBER OF SUGGESTIONS
MADE BY THE MEMBERS HERE WILL
WHO DEEMED THAT LATEST ONE THE
BUILD SOME AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY
THE BEACH LEVINE AMEND THAT.
I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER BILL.
MISTER SOX.
THINK IT WAS SHARE JUST QUICK
QUESTION.
CAN I THINK MY VOTE PROBABLY
HINGES ON YOUR ANSWER HERE.
WHERE IS THE MOST TECHNICALLY
MOST ADVANCED ENGINEERED?
WAVE IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MISTRESS ALICE YOU
BEST A BEARD THE EARLIER PART OF
OUR PRESENTATION WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT YOUR. DISTRICT MISTER
CALDERON.
YEAH IT'S IN YOUR DISTRICT WE
GET IT THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT. AND WE'RE HONORED TO HAVE
YOU AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR ON
THIS BILL VERY APPRECIATE THAT
ALSO LIKE THAT THE COMMENTS
ABOUT INCLUDING MAYBE SOCCER AND
STUFF IN THE FUTURE.
DO HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS.
WE'RE SEEING NINE. WE'VE HAD A
LIVELY DISCUSSION ABOUT THE.
.
STATES FOR HERE TODAY.
AS A.
.
COMMITTED SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
RESIDENT IN.
REPORTER AGRICULTURE AND A. THE
COMMUNITY I I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE MISTER A BIGELOW AS
COMMENTS ABOUT THE RODEO. ALSO
IS A.
FORMER STUDENT YOU SEE S. B. IN
A RESIDENT ISLA VISTA FOR SOME
YEARS I MAY KNOW SOMETHING.
YEAH ABOUT THIS CERTAIN SPORT
YOU SPEAK OF.
CAMPUS POINT MISTER JACK.
APPRECIATE DOT BRINGS FOR I DO
SEE ONE MORE QUESTION COMING
FROM THE COMMITTEE MISTER
COOLEY.
MISTER COOLEY. IS WAVING HIS
COMMENT.
WITH THAT SEEING NO MORE
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS TO WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
SECRETARY PLEASE PAT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL IT'S TO PASS. NOT TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR GOING BY.
GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA PIE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER. COOPER AYE
DALY. DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
IT.
IT'S GONNA.
OKAY NUMBER. NO LONGER NOW
FLOATING EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I SAW THIS.
SOLIS AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE.
I THINK THAT BILLS OUT.
OKAY MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
CALL.
WE'RE GONNA LIFT THE CALL AND
EIGHTY BE TWENTY THREE OO EIGHT.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO.
EDUARDO GARCIA. GIPSON.
GIPSON NOT VOTING. GLORIA.
GLORIA I.
LOW.
AND FOR.
I'M.
RUBIO.
RUBIO NOT VOTING SOLACE.
SO IT'S NO.
MR.
ON TWENTY THREE A A.
WILLOW NOT VOTING.
THAT BILL FAILS.
WE'LL LEAVE.
THE ROLE OPEN FOR TWO MINUTES
FOR AN OUNCE
COMMITTEE INJURED